Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Stefan. Führerschein und Fahrzeugpapiere bitte.
Oh, schon wieder ey. Ne, kein Problem. Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik mit einem Spezial, ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung,
welche Folgen-Nummer es ist, aufgezeichnet an einem variablen Ort.
Wir sind in einem Fahrzeug. Wir sind im Adenauer SAP Plus.
Im Demomobil des Zentrums für politische Schönheit mit dem Eskalationsbeauftragten
des Zentrums für politische Schönheit, Stefan.
Hi, ja ich freue mich mega wieder da zu sein.
Wir sind quasi auf der neuen Jungfernfahrt des Adenauers mit neuer Tür.
Das hat uns auch gerade bei der Abfahrt noch echt Kopfzerbrechen bereitet,
weil die Polizei hat ja die Tür eingeschlagen gehabt, aber dazu später bestimmt mehr.
Dann wurde sie erneuert und jetzt wollten wir losfahren und sie ging nicht zu.
Aber wir haben es geschafft, jetzt sind wir unterwegs.
Willkommen im Adenauer, Linus.
Ich bin begeistert. Ich habe ja schon mal auf dem Kongress begutachten dürfen,
auf dem Aufbau und hatte diese ganzen Dachaufbauten noch nicht.
Ich möchte aber direkt die eine Anekdote direkt loswerden.
Und zwar an Tag 1 des CCC-Kongress kommen ja sehr viele Presseleute.
Und die machen dann so Interviews und Fernsehinterviews und so.
Und wir betreuen die ja da.
Und dann habe ich so, die sagen, was gibt es denn Schönes hier zu sehen?
Und dann sage ich, wir haben da so einen schönen Bus.
Und ich habe dann auch die Tagesschau-Interviews immer schön vor dem Adenauer gegeben.
Und bei mehreren Fernsehteams war das so, ey, ist aber nicht der Adenauer.
Und dann so, ja doch, doch, doch, also bevor wir überhaupt da waren.
Ja doch, wir haben den Adenauer hier. Geil, ich habe gespendet.
Mehrere von der Systempresse haben das hier mitfinanziert.
Von der Lügenpresse.
Von der Lügen- und Systempresse haben das mitfinanziert. Wir müssen aber kurz
erklären, was ist überhaupt der Adenauer?
Ja genau, der Adenauer, also deswegen, das wundert mich jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht auch, dass die da alle mitfinanziert haben, denn der Adenauer ist ja sowas
wie die neue Volksaktie geworden, Wahrzeichen der Demokratie. Was ist das?
Wir vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit, wir haben gedacht,
was machen wir diesen Winter, um uns den Winter so ein bisschen zu erhellen
und um die Fackel der Zivilgesellschaft hochzuhalten gegen den aufkommenden Faschismus im Land.
Und haben uns dann überlegt, dass wir einen Bus umbauen zum Gefechtsstand für
die Zivilgesellschaft und haben das Ganze dann, ich glaube am 11.
Dezember, präsentiert der Weltöffentlichkeit in Form von einem Video,
wie wir uns das vorstellen, also ein Reisebus mit einem riesen Dachgepäckträger,
mit Wasserwerfer drauf, Lautsprecher, Beamer,
alles, was man sich so in seinem LED-Leinwände...
Also das Limit war der Himmel, sagen wir es mal so. Alles, was sich irgendjemand
vorgestellt hat, was man haben wollte, wurde gleich mit eingebaut.
Also das ist der Daraufbau.
Innen ist alles, ich weiß nicht, Linus, du kannst dich ja mal umgucken, ob dir das auffällt.
Aber wir haben das versucht, möglichst komplett umzugestalten und den Nief eines
westdeutschen Polizeireviers der 60er Jahre.
Das ist euch wirklich gelungen. Wir haben hier ein Präzitronik-Funkpult,
wir haben Röhrenbildschirme, das sind Telexgeräte, oder?
Ja, wir haben da Logs draufgeschrieben, der Monitor funktioniert damit und dann
haben wir unseren Touren immer geschrieben, so, nächster Eintrag,
die Kollegen in Berlin haben uns kontrolliert und genau, dann ganz viel GDP,
man kann nicht genug hier,
Gewerkschaft der Polizei, Merch an Bord haben.
Kalender von der Gesellschaft der Polizei, Kugelschreiber, das Poster.
Unser Erfolg steht auf 384.496 Beinen, die GdP.
Genau, aber was dir vielleicht nicht auf den ersten Blick auffällt,
wir haben das so ins Unglaubliche getrieben. Diese Dreckgeschichten hier, die du siehst.
Nee, jetzt sag ich den ja gleich auch noch.
Die haben ja den gemalt. Ja, da kam ein Patina-Maler, um hier Patina zu malen.
Hier auch um das Telefon rum, siehst du das, dass es so ist.
Nein, wirklich?
Wir rauchen ja hier nicht, hier ist aber ein Aschenbecher aufgeklebt, der ist angeklebt.
Damit der nicht die ganze Zeit aufbaut hat.
Genau, das ist ein Theaterset, wenn du so willst. Und wir haben das wirklich,
also innen pfui, außen hui mäßig aufgezogen, sodass man sich hier drinnen fühlt, wie im, genau.
Der TÜV, der Lux Neonröhrenlampe mit Osram ist noch TÜV geprüft bis 2025.
Ja, das gibt es als Aufkleber zu kaufen. Wir haben uns überall,
nachdem wir das erste Mal, aber dazu kommen wir gleich, kontrolliert wurden,
haben wir uns nochmal einen richtig großen Stapel geprüft Aufkleber geholt.
Und überall, siehst du, ist alles geprüft hier. Also in dem Fahrzeug ist wirklich,
das ist das geprüfteste und jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von unseren Aufklebern,
ist es das geprüfteste Fahrzeug, was in dieser Republik überhaupt je gebaut wurde.
Geprüfter als die Brandmeldeanlage vom Flughafen Berlin-Brandenburg.
Wir haben, also vielleicht, das ist ein Bus der Marke, also ich kaufe...
Mercedes natürlich. Und drunter machen wir es nicht mehr.
Und das ist ein Passagierbus, 12,50 Meter lang?
12,15 Meter. Genau diese 15 Zentimeter sind auch ein Problem,
wenn man in die Fahrzeugtechnik einsteigt.
Weil ab 12,15 Meter bist du tatsächlich nur noch als Reisebus überhaupt unterwegs.
Also kein LKW darf 12,15 Meter sein, kein Wohnmobil. Die magische Grenze verläuft bei 12 Metern.
Ab 12 Metern muss ein Bus sein. Und deswegen muss er auch mehr als neun Sitzplätze
inklusive Fahrer haben.
Und der hier hat jetzt gerade noch zwölf, meine ich.
Aber wenn du runterbaust auf nur noch acht, dann hast du keine Betriebserlaubnis mehr.
Aber wir fahren ja immer nur mit Betriebserlaubnis überhaupt durch die Gegend.
Wie breit ist der?
2,55.
Und dann ist der 4 Meter hoch oder was?
Also original 3,30 Meter und unsere Aufbauten sind im zugeklappten Zustand,
nämlich in dem Zustand, wie wir gerade fahren.
Sehr verständlich.
In dem sind die Aufbauten insgesamt 3,94 Meter und auch da sind wir 6 Zentimeter
quasi entfernt von der maximalen Höhe, die irgendwas in Deutschland haben kann von 4 Metern.
So, das ist er also, der Adenauer, der jetzt hier wirklichkeit geworden ist,
der feuchte Traum eines jeden Ingenieurs, ob DEKRA oder anarchistische Poco-Partei,
alle finden was an dem Fahrzeug.
Und wir haben dieses Fahrzeug quasi präsentiert auf unserer Webseite und in
den Social Medien und auch natürlich über unsere Newsletter aufgerufen,
die Volksaktie zu kaufen,
quasi sich Anteilsscheine am Adenauer SRP Plus zu kaufen, damit dieses Fahrzeug
Realität werden kann und das hat sich sofort zur Volksaktie entwickelt.
Wir haben innerhalb von 48 Stunden, glaube ich, den damals geplanten Preis vom
Adenauer ausfinanziert gehabt.
Das war noch ohne die ganze Polizeischikane gerechnet und was dazu kommt.
Aber grundsätzlich erstmal sind uns die Aktien aus den Händen gerissen worden.
Weil ihr einen Zweck für dieses Fahrzeug habt, den haben wir noch gar nicht benannt.
Genau, Grund und Zweck war es, den Wahlkampf, also das haben wir plakativ so
gesagt, zerstöre den Wahlkampf der AfD. Denn dieses Fahrzeug sollte überall
dorthin fahren, wo die AfD auf Stimmenfang geht, gleichzeitig aber auch zivilgesellschaftliche
Proteste unterstützen.
Und das haben wir dann auch gemacht, an allen Tagen, in denen wir nicht beschlagnahmt waren.
Das Fahrzeug sieht aus von außen wie ein Justizbus.
Also der ist jetzt silber, draußen blauer Streifen, steht drauf Adenauer SRP Plus.
Genau.
Dann sind die Fenster so schießschadenmäßig irgendwie, wie sich das für ein Gefängnisbus gehört.
Genau, es ist ein Gefangenentransporter.
Wir stehen an der Ampel, die Leute gucken, also es ist auch schon sehr...
Das ist ein Fahrzeug, das ist so, drive the emotion war glaube ich von Sixt oder sowas die Werbung.
Drive Sixt and feel the motion, da kann ich nur sagen drive Adenauer and feel the motion.
Weil dieses Fahrzeug ist wirklich, man kann das sogar an Bezirken festmachen,
in manchen Bezirken kriegt man irgendwas zwischen Mittelfinger und Elongruß gezeigt,
in anderen Bezirken gehen die Handys hoch, die Fäuste und so weiter, genau,
also es ist also wirklich für jeden Geschmack was dabei oder nicht, kann man nur sagen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Fahrzeug, was keinen kalt lässt.
Genau, der wurde also dann finanziert und wir haben angefangen zu bauen.
Beziehungsweise, genau, ziemlich schnell mussten wir ja bauen,
denn aufgrund des Endes des Kabinettscholz und dem vorgezogenen Neumann hatten
wir sehr, sehr kurze Bauphasen.
Das führte dazu, dass quasi der Dachträger wurde in einer Werkstatt gebaut,
im Zweischichtbetrieb von früh bis spät.
Gleichzeitig wurde der Bus zugelassen, begutachtet.
Dann waren wir ja zwischenzeitlich, also mitten in der Bauphase,
hat dann auch noch so ein Kongress uns das Fahrzeug für eine Woche weggenommen.
Ihr konntet da ja weiterbauen.
Genau, ein bisschen weiterbauen ging, aber dann war der mitten in der Bauphase beim CCC-Kongress.
Nach dem CCC-Kongress wurde dann alles quasi zusammengefügt,
also Dachträger und Fahrzeug selbst.
Letzter Schliff wurde gemacht, es wurden in die Zellen, die war hinten, wir haben ja 1, 2, 3,
sechs, sieben Zellen für Insassen des Gefängnisbusses.
Da wurde noch ein bisschen Technik eingebaut und dann haben wir glaube ich am
einen Monat nach Baubeginn und
das muss man sehen, dass das in Deutschland überhaupt noch möglich ist.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn Fahrzeug von der Pike auf zu entwickeln,
Ich wette, wenn sich der Freistaat Sachsen einen neuen Gefangenenbus,
nicht vor KW40 2028 ist da und dann noch mit dreimal Verzögerung doppelter Preis.
Und dreimal Verzögerung doppelter Preis und nicht finanziert.
Ja, genau. So, das ist also die kurze Wertensgeschichte vom Adenauer,
bevor er dann in den Regeldienst gestellt wurde.
So, was hat das Fahrzeug für eine Ausstattung? Wir sind hier allein schon in
der Lage, mein Recording-Equipment anzuschließen und über 230 Volt zu versorgen.
Ja, wir haben also da keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut.
Hinten im Heck verbaut sind 24.000 Watt Lithium-Speicher.
Die können wir laden, unterwegs auch. Also erstmal, wenn wir fahren,
laden wir aus der Fahrzeugbatterie 5 kW nach.
Aus der Lichtmaschine die lädt dann ein zweites Batteriepack und von dort geht
es dann weiter in die 48 Volt Batteriespeicher,
genau und aus diesen 24.000 Volt haben wir dann Drehstrom,
24.000 Watt ja genau richtig 48 Volt 24.000 Watt,
da sind drei Wechselrichter dran die quasi die zusammen dann 15 kW Drehstrom generieren.
Wir brauchen zwar für fast nichts Drehstrom, aber für unsere Sirene.
Wir haben eine Sirene auf dem Dach und die braucht Drehstrom.
Genau, das ist die Katastrophensirene Typ Evelina.
Die Katastrophen? Wo kriegt man die Katastrophensirene Typ Evelina?
Ist die irgendwie beim Warntag?
Ja, die ist abgebaut. Die ist alles deutscher Katastrophenschutz.
Also wirklich hat Hand und Fuß. Und wir haben rausgekriegt, das ist einfach die lauteste.
Und um das rauszukriegen empfehle ich die Lektüre von sirenenforum.de sirenenforum.de,
da haben wir uns angemeldet und nach Sirenen recherchiert und dann musste es
die Evelina sein, die E56 ist das.
Und wo kauft man die Sirenen24?
Die gibt es bei irgendwelchen Nerds auf eBay Kleinanzeigen in der Garage abzuholen
mit noch der Ansage, die funktioniert und so probieren darf man die nirgendwo,
die ist zu laut also keiner kann das in seinem in seinem,
Garage am Streberhaus, weil so, also Sirenen-Nerds wohnen meistens in Doppelhaushälften
und haben dann ein Problem mit ihrem Hobby. Das ist so ein Scheiß-Hobby.
Also, wenn du sagst, mein Hobby sind Luftschutz-Sirenen.
Ich kann dir die funktionieren, aber ich kann dir das jetzt nicht zeigen.
Genau, ich kann dir das jetzt nicht zeigen, genau, geht nicht.
Was kostet so eine? Wenn ich jetzt beim Sirenen-Nerd...
Ich glaube, 300 bis 500 Euro bist du dabei, aber die wiegt 160 Kilo oder 140.
Die Daten, das Datenblatt, man kann da ruhig einen Fact-Check drauf machen,
Ich bin da nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber E56, es gibt wirklich Shownotes, kann ich nur verweisen.
Es gibt da wunderbare Dokumentationen dadurch, dass es originärer deutscher
Katastrophenschutzstandard ist.
Das Ding ist durchdokumentiert.
Genau, natürlich. Was mich daran überzeugt hat damals, es waren ja mehrere Sirenen
in der Auswahl, waren, dass es da so Karten zu gab, wo so hinterlegt wurde,
wie weit kann man warnen damit.
Und man kann 14 Kilometer, meine ich, auch da nicht hundertprozentig,
aber sie ist ausgelegt für 14 Kilometer Warnreichweite.
Mit wie viel Dezibel?
Also die Polizei behauptet, sie hat 108 Dezibel gemessen auf 20 Meter.
In dem Bereich bewegt sich es auch, man muss dazu sagen, das ist so ein Sound,
der geht so richtig gut durch den Magen.
Also eine Motorsirene ist kein ekliger Hochton-Sound.
Nee, das ist dieses Wuuuuh.
Genau. Und wenn die dann, die dreht sich so im Kreis und dann hast du so ein
richtig, das geht halt, du spürst die im Bauch.
Und die, es ist aber relativ einfach, wenn man sich die Ohren zuhält,
sein Gehör zu schützen. Das dringt nicht durch die zugehaltenen Ohren.
Du hörst sie ja noch im Bauch sozusagen. Das hat was, ich glaube,
400 Hertz oder so, hat so eine Katastrophenschutz-Sirene.
Jetzt habe ich den Eindruck, dass du die auch steuern kannst.
Du kannst die Drehzahl von dem Ding die verhält sich nicht immer so wie man
das vom Warntag kennt oder so es.
Gibt ja auch Sachen die sind verboten also man darf bestimmte Warnungen nicht
machen, du darfst ja nicht einfach so tun als sei jetzt,
gerade als sei jetzt gerade,
Flugalarm die Russen kommen wir haben hier glaube ich weiß nicht,
ob es noch hängt da hinten, so eine Warnscheme, ein Hängen, die man nicht benutzen darf.
Und was man aber immer darf, ist entwarnen.
Du hast dann eine bestimmte Frequenz und sagst, eine Minute an,
dreimal für zehn Sekunden unterbrochen ist XY. So funktioniert Warnung.
Da fragt man sich natürlich als Bürger, wer...
Weißt du es. Also, wenn du so,
stell dir mal vor, du sitzt bei deinen Eltern irgendwo auf dem Land und dann
geht so eine Sirene los und dann sagt deine Vater, ja klar, das ist Feuer oder
das ist, nee, jetzt ist Atomkrieg.
Genau, das ist, ich bin zumindest in der Schule nicht mehr großartig unterrichtet worden in Sachen.
Das ist eine hohe Kunst, die auch in Vergessenheit geraten ist.
Genau, auf jeden Fall.
Aber ihr fahrt dann, und das ist einer der Gründe, warum ihr quasi andere als
die normalerweise vielleicht bekannten Samstagnachmittag Kaffee kochen oder
Kartoffelwasser aufsetzen,
Signal, das dürft ihr quasi gar nicht machen.
Nee, genau. Also man muss sich eh fragen, was man so darf und was nicht,
also in welcher Lautstärke ganz kurz.
Ich würde zum Beispiel glauben, dass man das gar nicht darf,
sich so ein Ding aus dem Auto baut.
Wieso Ladung? Ladung ist letztlich erstmal alles. Das ist ja Ladung, muss man sehen.
Wir transportieren die erstmal.
Wir transportieren die erstmal nur zum Beispiel. Jetzt ist sie auch nicht betriebsbereit.
Jetzt ist sie nicht betriebsbereit und das heißt erstmal Ladung.
Was darfst du auf dem Auto haben?
Alles, was du auf deinem Anhänger haben darfst. Also fällt dir irgendwas ein,
was du nicht auf deinem Anhänger haben darfst oder in deinem Kofferraum?
Ja, Maschinengewehr, wenn du keinen Waffenschein hast oder so, aber so eine Sirene.
Wird selbst mit Waffenschein, das ist wahrscheinlich schwierig, Maschinengewehr.
Im Kofferraum.
Aber habt ihr auch hier auf dem Dach jetzt, oder was?
Maschinengewehr nicht, aber Sirene. So, und das heißt, es ist erstmal Ladung im Straßenverkehr.
Und dann kommst du in einer Versammlung an, zum Beispiel in Riesa haben wir
eine Versammlung angemeldet und in dieser Versammlung darfst du dann sagen,
jetzt will ich aber warnen vor dem Faschismus.
Und dann darfst du das natürlich wieder und wenn du nicht beauflagt wirst mit
einer bestimmten Dezibelgrenze,
dann darfst du das halt auch einfach erst mal. Wir fahren in die falsche Richtung,
gerade, das will ich mal mit Piet sagen.
Piet, wir fahren, was sagt denn dir dein Navi?
700 Meter. Und dann aber drehen oder hoch? Ah ja, Blumenberger.
Ich kann von hinten vorne nur in Hagen legen.
Okay. Ich gehe mal kurz zu ihm hin, oder?
Mhm.
So, wir sind nämlich tatsächlich mit dem Adenauer unterwegs und Piet ist heute
unser Fahrer, mit dem werde ich mich gleich auch ein bisschen unterhalten,
aber man kriegt mit diesem Fahrzeug nicht so gute Parkplätze,
und wir suchen jetzt gerade den Ort auf,
wohin jetzt zum ersten Mal beschlagnahmt wurde.
Stefan hat es jetzt gerade schon gesagt, es handelt sich um ein Protestmobil,
das den Wahlkampf der AfD und politisch angrenzenden Parteien begleitet hat.
Und viel,
Problemchen geschaffen hat.
So, wo waren wir? Sirene. Ich hatte gerade gesagt...
Man darf alles auf dem Dach haben.
Man darf alles auch schon wieder ein guter Titel für die Sendung fasst.
Übrigens nochmal für die Leute zum Zurückhören. Ich war das letzte Mal in der Sendung.
Da war es, die Anwälte sind die wahren Künstler. war der Sendungstitel am Schluss.
Und das lässt sich auch wieder eigentlich eins zu eins, also beziehungsweise
hier in dem Fall die Prüfer sind die wahren Künstler.
Oder man darf alles auf dem Dach haben.
Ist eigentlich auch ein schöner Titel.
Bei deinem letzten Besuch hast du vor allem euren Wunsch, dass ein Verbotsverfahren
gegen die AfD angestrengt wird, nachdrücklich vertreten.
Der ist hier in ein Fahrzeug gegossen. Das Ding sieht ja aus wie ein gefangenen Transporter.
Es ist letztlich die Fortsetzung der damaligen Aktion.
Denn wir haben hier wir haben ja damals den Olaf Scholz Deepfake quasi rausgebracht.
Mit dem Ziel, die Leute auf unsere Webseite www.afd-verbot.de aufmerksam zu machen,
wo wir damals 2000 oder 1800 jetzt über 2400 Beweise für die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit
der AfD gesammelt haben.
Und dieses Fahrzeug hier ist der rollende Beweis.
Also letztlich ist die Technik, die Sirene ist da, um vor dem Faschismus zu warnen.
Aber das Fahrzeug als solches hat die Möglichkeit, also erstens,
hier sind alle 2400 Beweise im Fahrzeug drin und zwar in der Hängeregistratur.
Ich hab hier auch ein paar Hängeregister.
Hier sind Beweise. Ich geh mal lieben, das war Beweise. Also und das ist hinten in der Zelle.
Ist das alles alphabetisch nach Person geordnet?
Sind hier sämtliche Beweise? Also das kommt daher, dass ja gerade ältere Politiker, Typ Merz, ne?
Die haben es nicht so mit dem Internet.
Wenn du willst, dass sie es verstehen, musst du es ausdrucken oder faxen.
Deswegen haben wir gedacht, wir drucken hier alles aus für die älteren Zeitgenossen.
Wir haben aber auch die Möglichkeit, hier alles abzubilden. Wir können auf die
LED-Wand Beweise legen, wir können auf die Fenster projizieren,
wir können auf das Rückfenster projizieren, wir können sogar auf Objekte projizieren,
weil hier ein Videoprojektor auf dem Dach installiert ist,
mit dem man Sachen projizieren kann, genau.
So, jetzt seid ihr mit dem Ding nach Riesa gefahren zum AfD-Parteitag, ne?
Ja.
Oder war das der, ja, das war der, nee, das war der Parteitag, genau.
Das war der Parteitag, genau, das war der, eigentlich der erste Einsatz von
dem Fahrzeug. Wir haben das präsentiert am Brandenburger Tor.
Da gibt es ein wunderschönes Video von dem, wie heißt der, Thomas Heise,
glaube ich, von Spiegel.
Das ist aber dann in Riesa, ne?
Nee, der war, ich glaube, der war am Brandenburger Tor und schaut dann,
dann kommt der Adenauer vorgefahren und er macht die Sirene an.
Und das bringt ihn so ein bisschen aus dem Konzept. Alter Walter.
Achso, sagt er in seinem eigenen Video und schneidet es dann nicht raus. Alter Walter.
Ja, also wir sind ja dann, also das war so, dass wir am Brandenburger Tor die
Präsentation hatten und dann wollten wir von dort direkt weiter nach Riesa,
um die Proteste gegen den AfD-Parteitag zu unterstützen und wir sind dann aber sofort,
also der sofort in unsere erste, also das war dann, dann kam die erste Episode
von dem Kontrollstress,
den wir hatten.
Denn unmittelbar nach dieser Präsentation, die ja ein Kunstwerk war,
sehr künstlerisch gemacht, hat der dortige Polizeiabschnitt.
Den Verkehrsdienst der Polizeibereich, also die Bus-Experten der Berliner Polizei gerufen.
Denen war das aber zu blöd, uns da vor der Weltöffentlichkeit zu kontrollieren.
Und dann haben die gesagt, nee, wir sollen hinterherfahren und haben es dann
vor der, ich glaube, vor der russischen Botschaft sogar oder vor irgendeiner
Botschaft in der Gegend unter den Linden mussten wir dann halten.
Und dann haben die gesagt, so, was ist das jetzt hier? Und haben erstmal ziemlich
blöd geguckt, muss man auch sagen.
Also stell dir jetzt vor, du bist Polizist vom Verkehrsdienst der Berliner Polizei,
wirst gerufen, kriegst wahrscheinlich als Information erstmal,
ja, da ist so ein Bus, der ist irgendwie komisch, hat ein paar Aufbauten.
Sag ich so, ja, logisch, fahr ich hin. Dann kommst du hier an und sagst,
ich will mal reingucken, guckst rein und bist erstens in einem alten Polizeirevier eigentlich.
Also der ganze Bus ist ein Polizeirevier vom Innenausbau her.
Dann gibt es hinten einen Zellentrakt. Da lässt du dir reinzeigen,
hinten in den Elektroraum.
Und das ist zwar alles wirklich ordentlich gemacht, aber es sieht trotzdem aus
irgendwie wie die Löthalle beim CCC.
Also wie die Kabel verlaufen und so weiter und so fort. Und du denkst erst mal,
was ist hier bitte schön los?
Dann guckst du in den Fahrzeugschein, da steht drin 59 Sitzplätze,
sind aber nur zwölf. War damals noch so?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das habt ihr sicherlich geändert.
Das mussten wir dann ändern, genau. Also es gab dann eine zweistündige Kontrolle,
aber die Polizisten haben das nicht, erstmal die ersten anderthalb Stunden lang,
wollten sie nicht verstehen.
Also das ist ganz wichtig, wenn man sich dieses Fahrzeug anguckt,
dass man es schafft, zwischen Fahrzeug und Ladung zu differenzieren.
Letztlich alle Probleme, auch rechtlichen Probleme und Unklarheiten,
die wir hatten. Es wird immer besser hier.
Wir sind doch Linienverkehr. So, alle rechtlichen Probleme, das war jetzt hier
gerade so, wir haben uns ein bisschen verfranst hier auf unserem Weg.
Aber so, letztlich ist es immer so, wenn du es nicht schaffst,
zwischen Ladung und Fahrzeug zu unterscheiden, dann kommst du mit dem Bus hier
bei jeder Kontrolle in Teufels Küche.
Warum? Weil erstens wirst du sagen, das geht alles nicht und zweitens wirst
du dann irgendwas aufschreiben und drittens werden unsere Anwälte dir die Hölle heiß machen dafür.
Weil es ein relativ klarer Fall ist. Aber die ersten Kollegen,
das haben wir dann auch erst gemerkt, haben das anderthalb Stunden nicht gecheckt
und haben gesagt, nee, also das geht wirklich überhaupt nicht,
dass diese ganzen Sachen auf dem Dach hier fest installiert sind.
Da haben wir gesagt, die sind nicht fest installiert.
Doch, die sind fest installiert, weil hier sind ja Schrauben,
die gehen aber nur in diese Reling und sie wollten es nicht verstehen.
Zwischendurch hat sich der Polizist, ich musste ihm erstmal,
das ist symbolisch eigentlich für die Berliner Polizei, erstens musste ich ihm
helfen, seine Leiter auseinanderzukriegen, die war so kaputt und er wollte ja aufs Dach rauf.
Dann musste ich ihm am Schluss helfen, dass er das überhaupt geschafft hat.
Zweitens hat er sich zwei Zigaretten bei mir geschnurrt, während der Kontrolle,
muss man auch dazu sagen.
Was?
Ja, ja, also es kommt alles mit unserem Comic, das gibt es alles demnächst als
Comic und das ist echt wahr.
Und dann hatten die so einen Riesenzettel geschrieben, was alles nicht geht
und so weiter. Dann haben wir die nochmal zur Seite genommen.
Also damals, das war dann der Punkt, alles nicht zulässig und außerdem noch
der Weitwinkelspiegel kaputt. Oder nicht da.
Und dann war so, okay, wir fahrt hier nirgendwo mehr hin.
Komm jetzt nochmal, ich erklär's dir nochmal. Das sind nur Spanngurte,
weil da oben auf dem Bus sind eigentlich zwei Relingen gebaut.
Wie man eine Dachreling kennt und darauf ist was draufgesetzt.
Und das nicht fest verbaut, sondern das ist mit Spanngurten festgezogen. Sonst nicht.
Mit dicken Spanngurten muss man sagen, es ist alles sicher, aber es ist trotzdem Ladung.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ah, warte mal. Dann hat man es ihm so aufgemalt, guck mal, so das.
Dann fängt der an, ach so und dann fängt er an, dann warte mal und streicht
auf seinem eigenen Zettel alles wieder durchgestrichen zwischendurch,
willst du noch eine Zigarette?
Noch weggestrichen, hab ich Pizza geholt, das ist auch weggestrichen,
aber Weitwinkelspiegel, der Weitwinkelspiegel und dann das so die Folien,
die hier außen dran waren, kein Prüfsegel hatten, aber das ist Killefitz, ne,
so, aber die am Schluss war im Prinzip alles weggestrichen, außer Weitwinkelspiegel,
können wir jetzt einfach fahren.
Weitwinkelspiegel machen wir nicht so. Nee, dann musste jemand kommen und uns
einen Weitwinkelspiegel noch schnell bringen, den wir dann so mit Gaffa-Tapes
so da drum getapet haben.
Das ist irgendwie, der ist damit man, der ist da, sehe ich den jetzt hier?
Ja, ich sehe ja jetzt den Weitwinkelspiegel. Das ist der Weitwinkelspiegel. Der kleine da oben.
Der Weitwinkelspiegel kann, genau, das kann dir auch nachher Piet,
unser Fahrer, der von Solibus, Solibus waren immer unsere Busfahrer hier in
dem Bus, ganz tolles Projekt, aber da zählt Piet nachher ein bisschen was zu,
und gibt es dann auch in den Shownotes bestimmt. stimmt.
Genau, das ist der Weidwinkelspiegel. So, also Weidwinkelspiegel war da, wir fahren nach Riesa.
In Riesa dachten wir, wir hatten uns so ausgeguckt,
ich hatte also erstmal, wir hatten schon jemanden vorher da,
der die Lage gecheckt hat, weil er ja klar war und mein Wunsch war es,
mein ganz persönlicher Wunsch, ich habe ja auch so ein bisschen so eine Privatfäde,
gegen die AfD am Laufen, also ich bin da wirklich engagiert in diesem Anti-AfD
Thema, da gehe ich richtig drauf, das ist wie so ein Hobby.
Genau. Und wir hatten dann jemanden vor, der sollte, der hat immer so die Lage
gecheckt und der meinte schon, hier ist eigentlich nur noch Polizei. Das war der Vortag.
Samstag war der Parteitag, Freitag war unsere Präsentation und dann sind wir
direkt weiter dahin gefahren, Freitagabend.
Das war so 22, 23 Uhr dort waren, nach dieser langen Polizeikontrolle.
Von dort kam immer nur, jetzt ist nur Polizei, alles nur Polizei.
Dann gab es eine Seite, die war für die Proteste vorgesehen und es gab die andere
Seite, die war nicht für die Proteste vorgesehen, sondern das war deren Protokollstrecke.
Also wo sie die Logistik für den Parteitag machen wollten.
Ich will aber auf die Seite. Ich will nicht zu der Demo, ich will dahin, wo ich nicht sein soll.
Da will ich hin. Und dann so, ja, wir fahren da einfach hin nachts,
da werden wir uns schon irgendwie hinstellen und so weiter.
Und dann so unsere Person vor Ort sagt, das Ganze vergessen,
da ist nur alles voll mit Polizei und so weiter. Und wir haben gesagt,
nee, wir machen das trotzdem.
Und sind dann tatsächlich eingesickert und sind da hingekommen,
wo wir hinwollten. Das war aber so eine Einbahnstraße auf der anderen Seite
vom Parteitagsgelände,
in so ein Industriegebiet, in so eine Einbahnstraße reingefahren und festgestellt,
dass es so ein bisschen wie der Bullenstrich, der Polizeistrich war.
Also da fuhren nur Polizeiautos hin und her und es hat keine 20 Sekunden gedauert.
Da kam Polizei und was macht ihr hier, was ist das hier für ein Auto und so weiter.
Und wir so, ja wir sind Veranstaltungstechniker, wir haben keine Ahnung,
wir sollen zu dieser Großdemonstration hinfahren.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, okay, wir bringen euch da jetzt hin.
Und unser Fahrer hat gleich gesagt, ich habe eigentlich keine Lenkzeit mehr.
Also, ich kann eigentlich gar nirgendwo mehr hinfahren. Ich muss genau hier
stehen bleiben. Also an dem Ort, wo wir halt sein wollten.
Und die so, nee, du musst aber jetzt hier wegfahren. Hier darf keiner von der
Seite hier nur die AfDler, auf der anderen Seite nur die dagegen sind.
Ja, aber wir können jetzt nicht mehr fahren.
Schreibst du mir dann einen Zettel, dass ich doch fahren darf?
Nee. Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir eskortieren euch jetzt trotzdem darüber.
Und wir dachten so, scheiße, das Rennen ist gelaufen gegen uns,
weil wir ja dann auf der richtigen, aber für uns falschen Seite sind.
Und da kannst du dann morgens, ja, kannst du ein bisschen lernen.
Da brauchst du dann die Sirene.
Ja, die Sirene hat auch auf der anderen Seite gut funktioniert.
So, jedenfalls mussten wir dann den Polizisten hinterherfahren.
Und auf der Hälfte der Strecke halten die eine Ampel an, kommen zu uns hingelaufen
und sagen, wir haben eine neue Anweisung, wir sollen euch doch wieder dahin
zurückbringen, wo ihr eben wart.
Wir so, was? Ja, da drüben, da geht gerade nicht, da ist irgendwie,
da ist gerade Anlieferverkehr.
Dann haben die uns also wieder dahin, zurückgebracht in unseren, in unsere,
in unsere Sackgasse und haben dann noch gesagt, jetzt dürft ihr hier schlafen,
und morgen früh um acht eskortieren wir euch da rüber.
So, dann haben wir uns also da hingestellt, haben noch ein Bier getrunken und
uns wurde versprochen, dass wir in Ruhe gelassen werden.
Können wir jetzt hier auch in Ruhe schlafen? Ja, ja, das versprechen wir euch.
Genau, dann haben wir uns also quasi noch ein Bier getrunken,
die Isomatten hier im Gang ausgerollt, haben uns gefreut, dass wir genau da
sind, weil dann war klar, es ist ja dann diese Panne durch die Medien gegangen,
ist ja so, dass ich die unbedingt wollte. Diese Panne wollte ich unbedingt haben.
Es war die Panne meines Lebens, sozusagen.
Das ist Pech aber auch.
Und es war dadurch, dass wir auf der richtigen, falschen Seite waren,
war klar, wir kommen auf jeden Fall an meinem Pannenort vorbei,
egal wann wir da wegkommen.
Also sofern die uns irgendwann nochmal rüberbringen zu dieser Versammlung,
zu der wir hin sollten, könnte es passieren, dass der Bus eine Panne hat.
Und der hätte sie dann auch an einer fulminanten.
Guten Stelle Welche Stelle war das denn?
Das war die Kreuzung direkt vor der Halle auf der Protokollstrecke.
Protokollstrecke heißt die Strecke, die sie nutzen wollen, um die Delegierten
dahin zu bringen, vor dem Parteitag.
Ich gehe aber zurück zu dieser Nacht, weil in der Nacht war es dann so,
dass das mit nicht, das war Pustekuchen, dass wir da in Ruhe gelassen wurden.
Wir wurden alle zwei Stunden geweckt von irgendwelchen sächsischen Polizisten.
Der erste kam an, da war nämlich wieder Spezialkommando Nutzfahrzeuge, wurde gerufen.
Wir wollen hier alles auslesen, Karte auslesen, Tacho auslesen.
Dann kamen später noch mal welche und irgendwann waren wir so,
es reicht, ich bin sauer nach vorne hingegangen und hab zu dem Polizisten gesagt,
sag mal, wir schlafen hier alle.
Weil der Antwort, ja, ich bin doch auch wach. Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
wenn ich mit dem Argument zu meinen Nachbarn gehe, weißt du, so um,
vier Uhr früh und klopfe oder sowas
und dann sag ich, wir haben ja mal geschlafen, ja, ich bin ja auch wach.
So, und dann ging das Ganze bis frühmorgens. Um sechs Uhr sind wir aufgestanden,
haben uns bereit gemacht, haben eigentlich gesagt, wir wollen jetzt gerne da rüberfahren.
Da war immer, haben die Polizei gesagt, nein, ihr dürft da jetzt nicht rüber,
weil jetzt ist gerade noch Demonstration, jetzt ist dies.
Es gab immer Gründe.
Und wir standen quasi eingekesselt,
eingekesselt hinter dem Polizeiauto und durften nicht los. Und das ging so weiter, ging so weiter.
Irgendwann habe ich gesagt, ich will aber jetzt wirklich los.
Und dann wurde uns um 7.50 Uhr gesagt, in 10 Minuten geht's los.
Und dann, wir hatten den Motor laufen, wollten losfahren, wollten abfahren und
später wurde uns dann um 8 Uhr uns gesagt, doch nicht.
Ihr bleibt hier den ganzen Tag, bis wir euch weglassen.
Und später in der Diskussion mit Polizisten wurde uns dann behauptet,
wir wären zu spät gewesen. Es wäre schon 8.01 Uhr gewesen. Um 8.01 Uhr hat man also dann,
sein... Jetzt, wo wir gerade angekommen sind, Wir sind jetzt beim Sicherstellungsgelände
der Berliner Polizei und hier sind wir eigentlich hingefahren.
Sieht jetzt unspektakulär aus, das ist hier auf der rechten Seite.
Sieht unspektakulär aus, aber hier war der Adenauer acht Tage beschlagnahmt.
Also dieser Bus hat hier acht Tage gelebt.
Und genau, bis er dann von hier zur DEKRA-Niederlassung geschleppt wurde,
hat er hier acht Tage lang verbracht.
Hinter Tor B.
Und dann wurden ja Fotos uns zugespielt.
Man darf ja nicht mit Drohnen über solche Gelände fliegen. Aber irgendjemand
hat es trotzdem gemacht.
Hat es wirklich?
Ja. Irgendjemand hat die Warnung weggedrückt, die bei DJI auf dem Display erscheint,
wenn man hier eine Drohne starten lassen will.
Okay, und er hat euch Aufnahmen zugespielt.
Genau, denn es wurde ja zugesichert, dass der trocken in der Halle steht und
er stand hier draußen im Schnee.
Ui. Genau, zurück nach Riesa.
Also 8.01.
Uhr, wir waren eine Minute zu spät.
An der Stelle, wo ihr festge...
Genau, und deswegen wurden wir da auch weiter festgesetzt. Und dann bin ich immer...
Wie muss ich mir das jetzt vorstellen? Also der Bus steht da.
So ein Bus, gut, da haben die den eingeparkt. Also ein Polizeiauto vor euch, eins hinter euch.
Nee, wir hatten nur eins, das waren so Lüneburger Polizisten,
die waren auch ganz nett, die haben die AfDler immer Muggel genannt in unseren
Diskussionen und wir waren aber in einer Sackgasse,
wo hinten so ein Wendehammer war, aber Fahrtrichtung raus und fünf Meter oder
zehn Meter vor uns stand ein Polizeiauto und das hätte jederzeit,
wenn wir losgefahren wären, nur so ganz leicht links fahren müssen und die Straße
wäre blockiert gewesen.
Ja.
So. Und die haben dann gesagt, nee, die Versammlungslage, die haben dann immer
ihren PF, haben sie den genannt, den Polizeiführer, angefunkt und gesagt,
dass wir uns beschweren, weil wir nicht zu unserer angemeldeten Versammlung
ja durchgelassen werden. Also, ne?
Und da kam immer nur zurück, ja,
ist mir egal. Also, die bleiben jetzt da stehen, die bleiben da stehen.
Und die Polizisten hatten einen Auftrag, an dem sind sie dann später auch grandios gescheitert.
Aber der eine Auftrag war, dieser Bus bewegt sich hier nicht weg.
Ich bin alle Viertelstunde hin.
Du hattest einen Auftrag, ich bewege den Bus hier weg.
Nicht weit, aber weg. Ich bin dann immer zu den Polizisten hin und dann habe
ich gesagt, so Leute, jetzt ist 8.30 Uhr.
Wenn der PF sich da nicht bewegt und wir nicht losfahren dürfen,
dann mache ich eine Demonstration ab 8.45 Uhr.
Hier, dann melde ich hier eine Spontanversammlung an und dann wird es hier richtig laut.
Und dann daraufhin hat der Polizist gesagt, okay, meldet er durch.
Um 8.45 Uhr bin ich hin und habe gesagt, was ist los?
Nee, noch keine Rückmeldung. Da habe ich gesagt, okay, letzte Frist setze ich euch jetzt 9 Uhr.
Dann geht es los. Bis um 9 Uhr war wieder nichts da.
Und da war auch klar zu dem Zeitpunkt, überall in Riesa wird blockiert.
Orte vorher sind Leute auf der Autobahn unterwegs.
Der AfD-Parteitag war leer bis dahin. Also eigentlich sollte um 9 Uhr Start
sein. Da war nicht ein Delegierter angekommen um die Zeit.
Und um 9 Uhr haben wir dann, bin ich hingegangen, also nein,
da habe ich gesagt, okay, melde ich jetzt eine.
Spontanversammlung an. Mit dem Thema freie Zufahrt zur Demonstration.
Der Adenauer muss hin oder das hat er sich dann aufgeschrieben.
Meine Personalien aufgenommen.
Dann hat er gesagt, ich gebe Ihnen eine Auflage, maximal 80 Dezibel.
Da habe ich ihm gesagt, das können Sie vollkommen vergessen,
denn es ist einschlägig in Urteilen anerkannt worden, dass die Menschen,
an die man sich richtet, in der Lage sein müssen, einen zu hören.
Und ich habe gesagt, die sind da, unsere Versammlungsteilnehmer sind 2000 Meter
weit weg, ich kann hier so laut sein, wie ich will.
Hat er hingenommen und ab dem Zeitpunkt haben wir dann die Sirene angemacht,
Nebel angemacht und man hat in ganz Riesa diesen Warnsound gehört.
Wir hatten damals so ein Problem, dass wir nicht, wir hatten es nicht so,
du kannst das hier in Berlin ja nicht so gut testen. Ich hatte das ja vorhin
mal mit dem, mein Hobby ist Sirene.
Und wir hatten das Problem, dass tatsächlich uns die Sicherung...
Das kannst du nirgendwo testen.
Ja, das kannst du nirgendwo testen. Wir haben schon überlegt,
wo man es, also in Deutschland zumindest, das ist ja relativ dicht besiedelt.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, mir wird jetzt kein Ort, kein irgendwo in Wisconsin
oder sowas, kannst du bestimmt gut so eine Sirene testen.
Irgendein Bunker oder so. Da flog tatsächlich die Sicherung.
Wenn wir auf volle Pulle gelassen haben. Und deswegen musste man dann immer
so leicht hoch und runter drehen.
Immer zwischen 80 und 100 Prozent, das ging.
Und so war das dann. Und man hat ganz riesig diese Sirene gehört.
Alle haben die Sirene gehört.
Zu uns kamen dann Journalisten, die einfach nur am Bahnhof angekommen waren
und so den Sirenen-Sound gehört haben.
Ich laufe der Sirene nach und guck mal, was da ist. Und so ging das dann relativ
lange sogar, bis 11 Uhr ungefähr, also zwei Stunden.
Zwischenzeitlich war dann sogar Spiegel TV da.
Und wir durften in Ruhe Sound machen. Das war auch okay. Man hat unseren Protest
gehört. Aber wir waren zunehmend unzufrieden mit der Situation.
Weil wir sagten, wir bleiben jetzt hier, bis das alles vorbei ist.
Und die lassen uns hier nicht raus.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, uns ist dann aufgefallen, dass die Polizisten relativ
häufig doch auf Toilette gingen.
Und dass niemals die von hinten nach vorne wechseln. Also in diesem Polizeiauto.
Also die vorderen zwei Polizisten steigen aus oder die hinteren steigen aus,
gehen pinkeln, kommen zurück, steigen wieder hinten ein.
Und die vorderen zwei steigen aus oder einer, gehen weg, steigen wieder vorne ein.
Also entweder haben die hinteren keinen Führerschein oder es gibt irgendeine
Art von Hierarchie oder Rangordnung, dass klar ist, wer hier sitzt hier vorne und wer hinten.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, wie lange braucht man wohl, wenn man von hinten
in so einem T5, das ist ja nicht so wie so ein Bus, hier bist du schnell vorne.
Aber man muss, wenn du vorne drei Sitze hast, du musst ja raus trotzdem,
wieder rum. Also, ja, überlegt, okay.
Und der Fahrer nicht vielleicht aus seinem Schlüssel.
Nächstes Mal, Pipi.
Dann werden wir mal gegen eine Auflage verstoßen hier. Weil eine der Auflagen
war ja, ihr müsst am selben Ort bleiben. Wir haben gesagt, okay.
Ja, ich gebe es zu, hier öffentlich sozusagen, ich habe bei einer Demonstration
in Riesa gegen eine Auflage verstoßen.
Das tut mir auch wirklich leid im Nachhinein. Ich habe mir große Vorwürfe gemacht.
Aber dann war der Plan, okay, wir könnten mal gegen eine Auflage verstoßen.
In dem Moment, wo Spiegel-TV gerade kam, das war lustig, es war jetzt nicht
geplant oder so, aber genau in dem Moment stehen halt diese zwei fordernden
Polizisten auf, bewegen sich vom Auto weg.
Der Fahrer muss vorne sein, aber darf nicht am Steuer sitzen,
das ist auffällig, sondern eher so rückwärts labernd, aber der Motor läuft,
das muss alles bereit sein.
Dann so, die gehen weg. Und dann war die Frage, gehen die nur so ein Stück?
Nein, die gehen weg, die laufen uns vorbei. Jetzt 20 Meter und dann so, okay, los.
Fahrer springt am Ding, haut den Gang rein und wir fahren mit der maximal erlaubten Geschwindigkeit.
Nur ganz knapp, nur ganz ein bisschen über den Bordstein, an dem Polizeiauto
vorbei, hinter uns der Polizist rennt, wie er nie in seinem Leben gerannt ist im Polizeiauto.
Aber es sind nur 200 Meter, also bis die überhaupt losgefahren sind,
sind wir schon um die Kurve, fahren runter und da kommt auch schon die Kreuzung, Vollbremsung, bumm.
Und dann haben Motorpanne gehabt, ne?
Schlimm. Sie sind auf nichts mehr verlass heutzutage bei diesen Fahrzeugen.
Es war so, ich muss dazu sagen, dass danach, das hat uns noch große Probleme
im Nachhinein, weil uns wurde ja vorgebracht, es sei eine illegale Abschalteinrichtung
zur Vortäuschung einer Panne installiert.
Das ist doch kein VW.
Genau, ist keine illegale Abschaltung.
Und man muss in dem Sinne dazu sagen, Epsteinum gibt es oder nicht.
Ich lasse das jetzt mal so ganz offen einfach hier. Ich würde das nie bestätigen.
I will not confirm, not decline, um es mit CIA-Deutsch zu sagen.
Die DEKRA hat festgestellt, es gibt sie nicht.
Und ich muss zu dieser Situation noch sagen, der Fahrer ist dahin gefahren,
dann haben wir gewechselt, ich habe mich vorne hingesetzt für die Kommunikation
mit der Polizei und ich habe den Polizisten, das sieht man da in Spiegel TV
und überall, gesagt, tut mir leid, wir haben eine Panne.
Erstmal, tut mir leid, ich habe gegen eine Auflage verstoßen.
Wir sollten uns nicht wegbewegen, ich habe es doch gemacht, es tut mir wirklich
leid, aber jetzt bleibt unsere Demonstration,
hier und außerdem habe ich leider dann eine Panne, das Fahrzeug geht nicht mehr
an und dann sage ich ihm so, guck und,
schalte, aber in dem Moment, wenn man nicht zumindest mal die Kupplung tritt,
dann passiert auch beim Schalten nichts.
Guck doch hier, geht überhaupt nichts. Und er sagt, okay, habe ich verstanden.
Das hat er sofort verstanden.
Es wurde nicht von polizeilicher Seite jemals überprüft oder sonst irgendwas,
ob das jetzt angegangen wäre oder nicht.
Das gehört zu dieser Wahrheit eben auch dazu, dass wir im Prinzip,
wenn du sagst Vortäuschen einer Panne mal ganz tief ins BGB-Gesetzbuch reingucken was das so ist,
strafbar nach Paragraphen, das sind Leute für lebenslänglich bekommen,
glaube ich in Deutschland, Vortäuschen einer Panne.
Wie dem auch sei, ein entscheidender Faktor war, ihr wurdet ja auch längere
Zeit an der Ausübung unserer.
Grundrechte gehindert und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, und das ist so,
wenn du eine Demonstration gesagt kriegst, okay, ihr werdet zwar irgendwas gehindert,
jetzt macht ihr eure spontanen Demonstration, dann werden sie nicht gelassen
und dann ist die Polizei weg und die laufen doch irgendwo hin.
Das ist ja das, was hier passiert ist. Eine Demonstration hat sich bewegt.
So, und dann kann die Polizei nicht sagen, ja, das hättet ihr nicht machen dürfen,
aber die Demonstration sagt, nö, wir bleiben aber jetzt hier,
weil jetzt demonstrieren wir hier weiter.
Ich glaube, dass das kein Gewinnerthema vor Gericht ist für die,
also für die Polizei, sozusagen.
Der Bus stand aber wirklich auch, also wirklich ungünstig, mitten auf so einer,
mitten auf der Kreuzung.
Genau, auf der Protokollstrecke, wo die, und dann war es für die Polizei nochmal
verhext, weil mittlerweile war es 11 Uhr und es waren immer noch.
Nur 20 Leute durchgekommen und am Schluss wurden die AfDler dann auf der letztverbliebenen
Straße quer durch die Innenstadt mit,
Niederflur-Gelenkbussen, also auch wieder mit Bussen,
wo wirklich ein Niederflur-Gelenkbus ist, ist einfach so ein Stadtbus,
so ein Schlenki, ein Gelenkbus.
Mit dem Gelenk in der Mitte.
Mit solchen und Stadtbussen wurden die da hingebracht und Und waren wir wirklich
zusammen gefärcht. Guck mal, wir haben auf jeden Fall Wir.
Haben schon eine.
Polizeieskorte. Natürlich mit dem Fahrzeug hast du immer Polizeieskorte.
Uns kann heute nichts passieren.
Ja, so. Und da in so einem, normalerweise hat so ein Niederflur-Gelenkbus 50
Sitzplätze, die haben da mit Stehplätzen und allem 150 Leute reingepackt in den Bus.
Da wurden wirklich so zusammen gefärcht wie Vieh, da zu ihrem Parteitag hingebracht.
Wir waren in Sichtweite, haben immer schön, immer wenn wieder ein Bus kam,
haben wir wieder die Sirene hochgefahren.
Am Schluss hat man so eine halbe, also hat man selbst einen halben Hörsturz davon.
Ich konnte das tagelang, habe ich das beim Einschlafen gehört.
Das gehört auch, ich sehe hier den ganz großen Karton mit den 3M Ohrenschonern.
Und das ist eher für Leute draußen, für Unbeteiligte, die wir schützen wollen.
Hinter uns siehst du auch, dass wir Ohrenschützer mit SRP Plus Branding haben.
Dazu haben wir natürlich auch hier Overalls mit SRP Plus Branding,
alles da. So, das war Riesa.
Ihr habt dann aber nachher, glaube ich, noch eine Party gemacht.
Es gab dann noch Videos mit ein bisschen Nebel und Strobo und Musik.
Als alle drin waren, also als der Parteitag losging, weil die sich selber für
beschlussfähig erklärt hatten,
sind wir dann weitergefahren zu der Großkundgebung und haben dort einfach noch
beschallt, haben als Lautsprecherwagen agiert und haben ein bisschen Party gemacht mit den Leuten.
Weil wir auch dann, wenn du fast 20 Stunden lang,
deine einzige Gesellschaft Polizisten in Kampfanzügen waren,
dann freust du, dann gehst du, endlich normale Leute.
Wenn du dann quasi auf der eigentlichen Demonstration angekommen bist.
Genau, von da so weit, so gut, so schlecht. Von da sind wir zurückgefahren nach
Berlin und interessanterweise hat sich für mich aus dem, aus diesem.
Ersten Kontrolle, die auf dem Weg nach Riesa stattgefunden hat,
hat sich dann so eine Art Brieffreundschaft entwickelt mit dem Polizisten,
der sich die Zigaretten geschnurrt hatte bei mir.
Oder seinem Kollegen, ich glaube, seinem Kollegen. Denn der hat,
und das ist auch was, was jetzt wahrscheinlich in Zukunft Gerichte beschäftigen
wird, denn der schrieb mir dann, hat gesagt, ja, alles gut, ich möchte aber, dass wir nochmal reden,
bevor wir nochmal eine Kontrolle machen müssen.
Deswegen, ich möchte lieber Sachen mit Ihnen kooperativ ausräumen.
Und so hat sich so ein Schriftwechsel, der wirklich aufschlussreich ist und
der in der Zukunft Gerichte quasi beschäftigen wird, entwickelt.
Denn ich habe so eine Brieffreundschaft alle zwei Tage.
Er hat geschrieben, er möchte gerne, also er hat über das Gewerbe zentral,
also kam an eine E-Mail-Adresse ran, hat da hingeschrieben.
Dann habe ich ihn zurückgerufen und dann haben wir E-Mails ausgetauscht und
telefoniert, denn er hat gesagt, ja, ich möchte ein paar Sachen noch anders
haben, ich möchte gerne, dass eine Stromprüfung gemacht wird, ich möchte dies,
ich möchte, dass eine Umwidmung gemacht wird, also von, weil das hier,
das ist sehr technisch jetzt, also er war von diesen 59 Sitzplätzen,
die es mal hatte auf und ich habe dem zugestimmt, ich habe gesagt,
ja, okay, das machen wir,
das können wir machen, also wir haben wirklich so eine Brieffreundschaft und
eine Telefonfreundschaft.
Gepflegt. Bis quasi ich irgendwann Vollzug meldete.
Da habe ich irgendwann gesagt, ich habe jetzt alles, was die Berliner Polizei,
er hat ja als Berliner Polizei Bus-Experte mit mir geschrieben.
Irgendwann habe ich ihm geschrieben, so, jetzt habe ich alles,
was du von mir wolltest, gemacht.
Fahrzeug umgewidmest von Eindecker auf E-Deck KLB nach Kraftfahrt-Bundesamtsschlüssel.
Eintragung der Dachreling.
Niederuntertragung auf diese Zwölfsitzplätze Folien mit Prüfsiegeln,
Brandmelderlack ist alles, wirklich alles gemacht was er wollte und einen Tag
später hat die Polizei dann das Fahrzeug beschlagnahmt,
Ich habe ihm aber auch noch den Satz reingeschrieben, leider aufgrund ihrer
Forderungen musste ich jetzt diese Umwidmung des Fahrzeuges im Fahrzeugschein
machen, das ist nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen, der Adenauer wird ihn also
jetzt dauerhaft auf Berlins Straßen erhalten bleiben,
Am nächsten Tag wurde das Fahrzeug dann beschlagnahmt.
Das war die Demonstration vor dem FD...
Genau, vor der C... Es ging bei der FDP los.
Ging bei der FDP los, ihr durftet ja nicht mitfahren.
Genau, und das Lustige war, das Fahrzeug wurde beschlagnahmt in diesem Zustand,
wir haben da vorhin drüber geredet, in dem Zustand, in dem es an einer Versammlung teilnahm.
Also es kam an und es wurde quasi dieser Aufbau unter Luftdruck gesetzt,
es wurde irgendwas ausgefahren, die LED-Wand hochgefahren.
Und uns wurde nicht erlaubt, also dann, und so wurde er beschlagnahmt und uns
wurde, wir haben dann gesagt, hier muss aber alles wieder zurückgebaut werden,
der Druck muss abgelassen werden, das muss alles wieder,
es war ein Lautsprecher zusätzlich montiert worden, naja, wir nehmen das genauso
mit, das war eh keine Kooperation und mit uns wurde gar nicht geredet,
das ist beschlagnahmt, beschlagnahmt, ich hab, und das Argument war immer,
da schließt sich der Kreis, warum hier illegaler Totschalter verbaut, Nö, haben wir nicht.
Ich habe Spiegel-TV gesehen. Also das Hauptargument jeglicher Polizeigeschichten
war immer, ich habe Spiegel-TV gesehen.
So, ne? Das kann dann irgendwann vor Gericht, ich habe Spiegel-TV,
also ich habe, mal gucken, wie gut das, ich habe Spiegel-TV gesehen,
vor Gericht funktioniert.
Und so, und dann war das Fahrzeug beschlagnahmt. Und wurde auf dieses Sicherstellungsgelände,
wo wir gerade waren, hinabgeschleppt. und wir haben es dann erstmal nicht mehr zurückbekommen.
Jetzt sind wir in Friedrichshain.
Nicht mehr in Hellersdorf.
Hier gehen nur die Arme hoch.
Wir fahren gerade am Frankfurter Tor entlang und überall gehen die Arme jetzt gehen die Fäuste hoch.
Und dann haben wir das Fahrzeug beschlagen. Das ist eigentlich super,
dass wir jetzt in Friedrichshain sind, denn wir holen in der Riga Straße, bei der ungefähr...
Da traust du dich mit deinem Auto rein.
Genau, ungefähr auf Höhe, sogar der Riga 94, Brennpunkt.
Dort holen wir ab Vasili Franco, der ist der innenpolitische Sprecher der Grünen
im Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus und in diesem Moment, wo das passiert ist,
hat er sich eingeschaltet und hat versucht zu vermitteln, denn für uns war die
Polizei nicht ansprechbar, gar nichts.
Wir haben es trotzdem insgesamt als Skandal empfunden da geht nicht,
Fahrradstraße Fahrradstraße so in Fahrradstraße, in die Riga, rein oder nicht rein,
ja so,
Geht doch, eigentlich so eigentlich ist es nicht. Ich glaube,
das soll jetzt schon in der ersten Ecke wieder raus.
Also wir fahren jetzt in die Riga rein und holen Vasili Franco ab.
Das ist der erste Podcast auf Rädern, glaube ich.
Das ist mein erster auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde es super. Man hört immer mal so ein Dude, Dude von den Blinkern.
Aber wir holen jetzt jemanden ab sozusagen und nehmen den ein Stück weit mit.
Diese Blicke, wie dieses Part, die Leute stehen da einfach und...
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir machen Pause, oder? Das darf man nicht sagen,
ich hätte so machen müssen.
Ja, hallo Vasili.
Hallo.
Wir haben dich jetzt an der Bushaltestelle Riga Straße in Friedrichshain abgeholt,
wo du geduldig auf deinen Bus gewartet hast.
Stell dich doch mal vor, was genau machst du und wer genau bist du?
Hallo, ich bin Vasili Franco. Ich bin seit 2021 Mitglied des Berliner Abgeordnetenhauses.
Hier direkt gewählt in Friedrichshain. Ihr habt mich hier abgeholt und bin dort
in politischer Sprecher, also für alles zuständig, was mit Polizei zu tun hat.
Und in dieser Rolle warst du zufällig auch bei der Demonstration vor dem,
was war das? Die Feuerwehrdemonstration.
Sie zündeln, wir löschen.
Ich war selber nicht bei der Demonstration, wir waren ja auch noch parallel
im Wahlkampf, aber man hat ja relativ schnell mitbekommen, da wurde ein Bus
auf einer Demonstration beschlagnahmt.
Deshalb habe ich Kontakten mit dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit aufgenommen,
um mal erfahren, was da denn passiert ist,
ob da irgendwelche Straftaten zugrunde liegen und seitdem war ich dann mehr
oder weniger täglich im Austausch mit euch, aber genauso mit der Polizei.
Wie oft wird denn so ein Bus beschlagnahmt in Berlin? Wie oft passiert das am Tag?
Also diesen Bus, der ist ja einmalig. Das passiert nicht so oft.
Also mir ist auch kein so Vorfall bekannt.
Eine Beschlagnahme kann ja stattfinden, wenn bestimmte Straftaten im Raum liegen,
aber als ich dann erfahren habe, was die Vorwürfe waren und erstmal auch versucht
habe herauszufinden, was ist denn die Rechtsgrundlage für diese Beschlagnahme,
habe ich selber, glaube ich, mehrere Tage gerätselt, bis dann ja rauskam,
es liegt gar keine Straftat zugrunde, sondern es gibt den Verdacht auf Ordnungswidrigkeiten.
Und das hat der Polizei gereicht, um einen Bus auf einer Demonstration zu beschlagnahmen.
Also schon ein starkes Stück.
Du bist juristisch, hast du einen juristischen Hintergrund?
Oder nur weil du im Abgeordnetenhaus sitzt, da mit einer Auseinandersetzung?
Oder wie ist also dein Hintergrund in dem Bereich?
Also ich sitze dort nicht nur, ich arbeite auch.
Aber du bist ja kein Angestellter, du bist ja Gewählter. Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich sage mal...
Alles in Ordnung. Den Witz wollte ich mitnehmen. Ich habe kein juristisches
Studium, beziehungsweise ich hätte lange gesagt, ich bin Verwaltungsrechtler.
Jetzt darf man das seit der Völkerrechtsgeschichte mit Annalena Baerbock nicht mehr sagen.
Aber ich habe Verwaltungswissenschaften studiert, also Bachelor und Master.
Schwerpunkt öffentliches Recht ist aber mehr so eine Generalistenausbildung,
damit man in allen Bereichen der Verwaltung fit ist. Aber ich würde sagen,
im Polizeirecht kenne ich mich doch mittlerweile ganz gut aus.
Auch durch meinen Job.
Und ja, die rechtliche Komponente als Innenpolitiker ist doch eine relativ wichtige,
weil oftmals geht es ja in der Politik darum, welche Gesetze machen wir,
was verändern wir, wo geben wir Geld hin.
Und gerade in der Innenpolitik kommt es ja auch sehr, sehr stark darauf an,
wie wird das Recht angewendet, vor allem wie wird das Recht angewendet durch die Polizei.
Und das finde ich ja, also ich kann mir vorstellen,
Nicht den Eindruck, wenn ich
jetzt auf Berliner Straßen mal so mit meinem ungeschulten Auge überlege,
wo denn vielleicht so die ein oder andere Veränderung an einem Fahrzeug,
hier zum Beispiel dieser Mercedes da, stattgefunden hat, die eventuell nicht eingetragen ist.
Das würde ja dann zum Erlöschen der Betriebserlaubnis führen.
Wir müssen erstmal zwei grundlegende Sachverhalte unterscheiden.
Das eine ist die Verkehrstüchtigkeit auf der Straße, also passt an dem Bus alles,
damit er auch auf der Straße fahren kann.
Das ist die eine Frage, die geklärt werden muss, aber dann ist auch ganz wichtig
zu beachten auf Versammlungen.
Die sind ja vom Versammlungsgrundrecht geschützt, dort gibt es nochmal andere Maßstäbe.
Ganz einfach, Fahrzeuge mit Lautsprechern und so weiter und so fort,
mit denen darf man in der Regel auch nicht am Straßenverkehr teilnehmen,
Aber auf Versammlungen eben schon.
Dort gilt eben ein anderes Recht. Das muss berücksichtigt werden.
Und das war eigentlich die Krux an der ganzen Geschichte, weil der Bus wurde
auf einer Demo beschlagnahmt.
Und dann wurde gesagt, naja, der ist ja gar nicht verkehrstüchtig.
Schaut euch die ganzen Aufbauten an.
Wohlgemerkt eben die Aufbauten, die erst auf der Versammlung ausgefahren wurden.
Das ist so, wie du musst dir das gleich so, ich kenne dir mal ein gutes Äquivalent.
Da gibt es auch verschiedene Rechtsgrundlagen, wie ein Wohnwagen auf dem Campingplatz
stehen muss und wie er auf der Autobahn fährt.
Also du kannst ja nicht auf den Campingplatz gehen.
Und dann hat jemand sein Vorzelt dran. So kannst du aber auf keinen Fall fahren.
Das nehme ich gleich mit, das ganze Ding. Also du musst natürlich schon immer
das in einem Kontext sehen.
Wie ist das? Und in dem Moment wurde uns quasi auf der Versammlung das Fahrzeug weggenommen.
Aber die Argumente waren ja gar nicht die. Die waren ja die Ovis.
Da wurde gesagt, Dachkonstruktion nicht zugelassen.
Da wurde gesagt, Totschalter verbaut, weil sie hatten ja Spiegel-TV gesehen.
Dann wurde gesagt, Absenkeinrichtung, also dass man den ganzen Bus bis auf den
Asphalt runtersenken kann.
Sowas gibt es nicht, hat noch nie jemand gesehen, ist wirklich reine Imagination.
Ich weiß nicht woher, uns wurde gesagt, uns liegen Informationen vor, dass sie das haben.
Und dann, was das Schlimme ist...
Ist das das mit diesem Druck hier?
Nee, dass man quasi das ganze Fahrzeug über die, bis auf den Boden herunterlassen
kann, aber uns wurde das nicht klar und das letzte,
war mir dann, was war denn überhaupt noch was für dich? Ich hab's schon wieder
ganz vergessen. Also das war dann auf jeden Fall nichts Relevantes mehr.
Aber der Punkt war, das wurde quasi uns vorgeworfen als Straftaten sogar.
Das wurde beschlagnahmt nach Strafprozessordnung. Und die Polizisten waren dann
auch in den nächsten Tagen gegenüber unseren Anwälten sehr herablassend.
Und haben gesagt, wieso, das dauert doch jetzt eh acht bis zehn Wochen.
Wir haben versucht, ein Eilverfahren anzustrengen auf gleichem Wege.
Aber die Polizisten waren sich relativ sicher in ihrer Sache,
dass es so eine Entscheidung über diese Maßnahme, dass wir hier über acht bis zehn Wochen reden.
Und so lange sollte der bei denen auf dem Hof stehen?
Eigentlich laut, was sie uns schriftlich zugesagt haben, in ihrer Halle stehen.
Aber Tatsache stand er ja da auf dem Hof, wie dieser Drohnenflug beweisen konnte.
So, und ich dachte, dass wir, oder das war der Grund, weshalb man dann auf einmal
tatsächlich eine politische Komponente braucht, denn der Fall ist aus meiner
Sicht ein politischer gewesen.
Also, ich beschlagnahme da was, ich werfe falsche Sachen vor,
so, und dann sage ich im Telefon, und sage dann am Telefon zu Gegenüber der
Anwälte, das dauert jetzt aber acht bis zehn Wochen,
also ganz herablassend, wo klar ist, okay, hier führt, aus meiner Sicht,
die dürfte sowas nicht in den Mund nehmen, aber hier ist ein Polizist,
der wirklich Blut geleckt hat und das unbedingt will und sich da so ein bisschen
auch verselbstständigt.
Und daraufhin haben wir halt politisch angefangen, Druck zu machen und dann
wurden Angebote vermittelt, also wo quasi gesagt wurde,
es werden, es reden Leute miteinander darüber und es wird gefragt,
warum, was ist da passiert, warum können wir das, wenn das so ist,
warum können wir nicht jetzt zur Dekra gehen?
Also warum können Wenn nicht heute, dann wurde gesagt, nee, erst muss das Gericht
entscheiden. Ja, wieso?
Unsere Anwälte haben gesagt, es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund.
Auch wenn du was beschlagnahmst, Strafprozess, und der Gegner klagt dagegen,
ist das kein Grund zu sagen, stopp, das war's, du kannst weiter ermitteln.
Und das heißt, es gab keinen wirklich guten Grund, nicht zu sagen,
warum treffen wir uns nicht übermorgen bei der DEKRA und klären das einfach.
So, und das haben wir aber, oder unsere Anwälte hinbekommen,
aber das wurde dann quasi vermittelt.
Genau. Eigentlich wäre das einfachste ja gewesen, wenn die Polizei ein Problem
mit diesem Bus hat, dann meldet sie sich bei euch, kommt zum Betriebshof,
schaut den mal an und stellt Mängel fest oder stellt sich eben nicht fest.
Hier war der Fall, der Bus war schon auf einer Versammlung, dann kommt die Polizei
rein, sagt, der wird hier sichergestellt.
Nee, warum? Der wird gleich beschlagnahmt.
Genau, wir nehmen den jetzt einfach mit. Also gar keine Begutachtung,
der Mängel vor Ort durch die Polizei und auch Auch vieles wurde ja gar nicht
festgestellt, deshalb schreibt man mal rein, Verdacht auf irgendwas und nimmt
diesen Bus von der Demonstration weg, weil so wie er auf der Demonstration steht,
so darf er ja nicht am Straßenverkehr teilnehmen.
Also ziemlich absurd, wenn jemand angehalten wird und da werden Mängel festgestellt,
kann man ja auch erstmal schauen,
naja, machen die Mängel dieses Fahrzeug nicht mehr sicher für den Straßenverkehr,
dann bring es zur nächsten Werkstatt und lass es dort reparieren.
Und hier hatte man einen Bus, der ja explizit für Versammlungslagen gedacht
ist, zwei Wochen vor der Bundestagswahl, zack, den nehmen wir jetzt hoch,
damit die auch möglichst in den nächsten zwei Wochen keine Veranstaltungen mehr nehmen können.
Also das ist doch eigentlich nichts anderes als ein Einfluss auf eine Bundestagswahl.
Ihr habt ja zwar nicht Werbung für eine bestimmte Partei gemacht,
aber gegen den Rechtsruck. Ja, und das zu Recht.
Ja.
Weil vielleicht nicht alle Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer so häufig an Demonstrationen
teilnehmen, ist ja schon relativ üblich, dass man ein Fahrzeug für eine Demo
in irgendeiner Weise ein bisschen herrichtet.
Sei es, dass da hinten eine Anlage drauf ist, sei es, dass auf der Ladefläche
von irgendeinem Transporter jemand hinten sitzt oder oben jemand Kamelle runterwirft.
Also es ist ja auch relativ normal, dass man das Fahrzeug dann auch im Rahmen
dieser Versammlung irgendwie in Schrittgeschwindigkeit bewegt und dann rennen
da irgendwie ein paar Ordner drumherum oder so.
Ja, oder selbst auf dem CSD und ein lustiges Beispiel, also der Adenauer war
ja dann am Samstag vor der Wahl, als er dann wieder frei war,
noch auf der AfD-Schlusskundgebung.
Da habe ich auch gesehen, so ein ganz altes, ausrangiertes Feuerwehrfahrzeug,
oben drauf, Boxen, Plakate und als das Auto weggefahren ist,
also dieser Bus von der AfD,
da hat das Plakat oben alles geflackert, also hätte die Polizei das hochgenommen,
wäre das sicher auch nicht verkehrstüchtig gewesen.
Ja, da haben sie dann irgendwie immer nicht so großes Interesse.
Ja, können sie ja nicht um alles kümmern.
Acht Tage stand der Wagen jetzt da.
Ja, acht Tage Nervenkrieg, aber das war jeden Tag, hier kann man das jetzt begutachten,
nein, wir wollen das wiederhaben, wir haben öffentlich Druck gemacht.
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ist das hier mit diesem Plakat in diesen acht Tagen
passiert oder war das dann noch danach, als wir den dann schon wieder?
Ich glaube, das war danach, als wir ihn schon wiederbekommen haben.
Oder ungefähr zum gleichen Zeitpunkt.
Oder ungefähr zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Nee, es war glaube ich dazwischen.
Aber das ist nämlich unser nächstes Ziel auf der Route, ist das Plakat vom Zentrum
für politische Schönheit, was die Polizei abgehangen hatte.
Letztlich kam es am Schluss, hat du die gefragt im Innenausschuss die Innensenatorin?
Zu dem Bus hatten wir nicht im Innenausschuss, sondern im Plenum gefragt,
also am Sonntag die Beschlagnahme.
Aber ich kann das gerne mal transparent machen. Seitdem war ich mit euch im
Austausch und dann auch mit der Polizei, weil ich schon auch thematisieren wollte,
so einen Bus zu beschlagnahmen im Vorfeld einer Bundestagswahl.
Das ist problematisch unter dem Aspekt der Versammlungsfreiheit,
der Meinungsfreiheit und der Kunstfreiheit und habe versucht,
eine gemeinsame Lösung hinzubekommen.
Also die Frage ist ja, wenn ein paar Mängel da sind, dann lass doch die Mängel
beheben und dann kann dieser Bus ganz normal wieder auf die Versammlung fahren.
Da hatte ich tatsächlich auch die Zusagen von der Polizei, dass man darauf hinarbeitet.
Das Interessante war dann, ich war dann auch immer wieder mit euch im Kontakt
und das, was von der Polizeiführung und später auch von der Senatorin und dem
Staatssekretär mir ja im Plenum gesagt worden ist, dass man jetzt einen gemeinsamen Termin macht.
Das wurde ein ums andere Mal, als die Polizei auf Arbeitsebene mit euch oder
euren Anwälten in Kontakt war, da wusste man dann plötzlich nichts mehr davon
oder hat dann erst auf Nachfrage reagiert.
Also man hat an jeder Stelle versucht zu verzögern.
Deshalb hat es erst mal eine Woche gedauert, über eine Woche gedauert,
bis es dann tatsächlich zu diesem gemeinsamen Begutachten-Termin kam.
Das muss man sich so vorstellen. Wir hören, quasi aus der Politik.
Ja, die Polizei machen eine gemeinsame Begutachten mit euch.
Die melden sich bei euch.
Bei wem melden die sich? Ja, beim Anwalt. Ja, okay. Ich rufe den Anwalt an.
Haben die sich bei euch gemeldet? Nö.
Warten wir den Tag ab. Zurück gemeldet. Hat sich keiner gemeldet.
Nächster Tag. Ja, nee, aber die melden sich. Haben die sich gemeldet? Nee.
Dann habe ich zum Anwalt gesagt, ja, meld du dich doch mal bei denen. Ruf doch mal da an.
Du bist da immer so out of the Box-Dingste da war.
Und dann sagte er, ja, ich dachte, also, und, aber wollen wir nicht,
wurde wieder nur angepumpt vom Polizisten, der Anwalt.
Hat sich dann aufgelegt irgendwann gedacht, und dann habe ich gesagt,
dann ruf den nochmal an und frag, ja, aber soll es nicht eine gemeinsame Begutachtung jetzt geben?
Und er so, ja, stimmt, hätte ich Ihnen sagen können, musste ich aber nicht.
Also, sie haben ja nicht gefragt.
Also, ganz, ganz, also wirklich, du kannst es fast nicht so dreckig vorstellen,
wie das am Schluss, also auf dieser Arbeitsebene lief.
Und genau so lief das auch am Tag der Begutachtung. Dann waren ja genau diese
federführende Polizeikraft, von der wir hier reden, nämlich...
Der Kippenschnorrer.
Nee, nein. Kein, der Kippenschnorrer, der war ganz am Anfang.
Okay.
Mit dem habe ich doch diese Brieffreundschaft gehabt.
Ja.
Ich dachte, der hätte jetzt seine Brieffreundschaft gehabt.
Nein, der Kippenschnorrer, mit dem habe ich sogar zwischenzeitlich telefoniert
und der hat gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was die da machen, andere Abteilungen.
Also, ne, sie sitzen auch woanders. Jetzt sind wir gleich oben,
guck mal, Da ist es, unser Plaketchen.
Da ist es, am Gorki.
Genau, wieder, muss man sagen. Es hängt nicht so schön, wie es vorher hängt.
Hat die Polizei das nicht so gut wieder hingehängt, ne?
Die Polizei hat es gar nicht wieder hingehängt.
Auf den Parkplatz hier rechts, würde ich sagen, stellen wir uns jetzt mal ein Momentchen, oder?
Gerne.
Genau, also du kannst doch hier wunderbar so stehen, so bis nach vorne da an
die Ecke ran, würde ich sagen.
So, genau, jetzt sehen wir nämlich das Plakat. Aber sollen wir erst noch die
Dekra fertig machen? Oder wollen wir jetzt zwischendurch kurz?
Das war wirklich ein spannender Tag.
Die Dekra-Geschichte erzählen wir jetzt.
Genau, dann war es nämlich dann so, dass am Schluss wurde dann gesagt,
okay, es gibt jetzt diesen Termin, aber auch wieder nicht am Freitag, sondern erst am Montag.
Also es war so, dann lag noch ein Wochenende dazwischen, so eine Sonntagbeschlagnahmt.
Freitag dachte ich, jetzt kriegen wir unseren Termin, aber dann doch nicht, dann halt am Montag.
Und eigentlich, dann hat es auch geheißen, von euch sind zwei Leute erlaubt.
Aber wir sind dann, glaube ich, so mit zehn bis elf, weil ich habe auch das
überhaupt nicht eingesehen.
Warum?
Ja, warum?
Allein schon mal mindestens neun Leute reinsetzen. Nein, zwölf Sitzer.
Muss man ja beschlagnahmt. Der wurde vom Autodienst Hoppegarten gebrannt.
Der und keine böse, ich lass nichts auf den Autodienst Hoppegarten kommen, ganz tolle Firma.
Also, weil ich hab gehört, nachdem die den schon, die hatten schon diesen Abtransport
von der Demo, war auch schon der Autodienst Hoppegarten.
Ja, die hab ich gesehen.
Und interessantes Funfact ist ja, dass die Polizei dann Desinformation verbreitet hat.
Die hat nämlich ein Foto von unserem Bus an die Presse rausgegeben.
Oder das Adenauer-Afford.
Wo der Adenauer wegretuschiert war, so ganz billig mit Paint mäßig.
Ich will aber nicht, dass da der Adenauer steht, wegretuschiert.
Wir haben gehofft, dass sie alle besonderen Kennzeichen von Autos entfernen,
aber bei Autodienst Hoppegarten nicht.
Aber vorne stand Autodienst Hoppegarten an dem vorderen. Und daraufhin haben
Leute den Autodienst Hoppegarten angerufen und bedroht.
Das habe ich erst bei diesem DEKRA-Termin gehört. Da bin ich hin,
da haben die uns das erzählt.
Weil das sind eigentlich ganz nette. Ich hatte sogar noch an dem Tag,
wo der Beschlagnahler wurde, damit er nichts kaputt macht mit dem Menschen.
Der Abschlepper ist nicht der Gegner, sage ich jetzt mal so.
Ich hörte auch, muss ich noch dazu sagen, ich stand da nämlich auch und dachte,
wer ist eigentlich dieser Autodienst Hoppegarten und sagte jemand,
der neben mir stand, der mir schon mehrfach meinen LKW repariert,
auf die lasse ich nichts kommen.
Ja, also genau. Ruft nicht beim Autodienst Hoppegarten an, weil der Autodienst Hoppegarten hat.
Es sei denn, wir müssen den Bus abschleppen.
Ja, aber die haben halt eine Ausschreibung des Landes Berlin und müssen dann
zu sowas kommen und die mussten auch an diesem DEKRA-Tag den dort hinbringen,
und haben aber selbst dort sich eigentlich,
haben es lächerlich gefunden, wie die,
Polizei oder der Polizist dort agierte, denn,
an dem Tag dort wurde dann quasi diese Kontrolle durchgeführt und der Polizist,
derselbe, der schon die ganze Zeit so pumpig und unangenehm war,
war auch wieder da und hat uns behandelt wie kleine Kinder.
Also auch den Anwalt, ich glaube selbst sogar...
Ja, ich war ja dann auch da. Wir hatten ja befürchtet, dass dass das auch etwas
eskalieren könnte, weil auch
das, was oben gesagt wird, unten anscheinend nicht immer angekommen ist.
Es hat ja auch super angefangen, der Bus wurde angeschleppt,
man hat noch den Schnee auf dem Dach gesehen, obwohl euch ja gesagt worden ist.
Und schriftlich versichert wurde, wir haben gesagt, Veranstaltungstechnik, die geht kaputt.
Jetzt haben wir hier so Pixelschäden in den LED-Panels und müssen gegen das
Land Berlin auf Schadensersatz klangen,
aber uns wurde schriftlich zugesagt, die Veranstaltungstechnik ist sicher,
denn der Bus steht durchgehend in der Halle Und dann ging es ja los,
ich habe gefragt, sie haben doch unterschrieben, dass der Bus in der Halle steht zu diesem Polizisten.
Stand aber nicht.
Und dann habe ich aber gesagt, ja. Aber da ist ja Schnee drauf.
Stand der in der Halle? Nein.
Ja warum nicht? Ja was weiß ich, wir sind 20.000 Polizisten oder so.
Dann haben wir gesagt, so, jetzt wollen wir mal kurz eine Sache klären.
Das Fahrzeug kommt hier in einem Zustand an, wie es nie am Straßenverkehr teilgenommen hat.
Sie haben es auf einer Demonstration beschlagnahmt. Wir wollen jetzt gerne mit
einer Viertelstunde ein paar Handgriffe machen und das Fahrzeug in diesen Zustand
versetzen, wie es am Straßenverkehr.
Nein, das wird so begutachtet. Ja, aber es hat ja so nicht teilgenommen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, das sind doch nicht dumm, die vom TÜV,
die können das doch unterscheiden, was hier so aufgebaut wurde und was nicht, sozusagen.
Und dann haben wir uns damit zufrieden gegeben.
Das Problem ist ja trotzdem von Anfang an, also die DEKRA kann ja nur begutachten,
was für den Straßenverkehr zulässig ist. Die haben ja einfach gar nichts mit Versammlungen zu tun.
Das ist dann alleine die Entscheidung der Polizei. Und wenn man sagt,
wir lassen diesen Bus in dieser Form bei der DEKRA einlaufen,
dann ist das Ergebnis eigentlich von Anfang an klar, der Bus wird nicht tauglich
für den Straßenverkehr sein, weil er im Demo-Zustand ist.
Und das war vielleicht auch durchaus eine Strategie. Das wurde ja über den Tag
durchaus noch interessanter.
Also die DEKRA hat sich alles angeschaut, war am Anfang auch noch so ein bisschen
skeptisch, weil wenn die Polizei da was vorwirft, werden da ja handfeste Mängel dran sein.
Da hat sich dann aber einer nach dem anderen in Luft aufgelöst.
Und der Polizist wurde immer hektischer, hat sehr oft mit der DEKRA geredet.
Ich durfte interessanterweise nicht zuhören, also als parlamentarischer Beobachter,
weil die Polizei etwas zu verbergen hat?
Also warum die Angst vor der Transparenz? Ich will ja auch nur verstehen,
was die Polizei da angreitet.
Und als ich einmal, das fand ich dann wirklich bezeichnend, mit dem Polizist
um den Bus gegangen bin, damit er mir mal ein bisschen erklärt,
also ich habe ja keine Ahnung, weder von Bussen noch von allen straßenverkehrsrechtlichen Regelungen,
wo jetzt denn genau die Probleme sind, dann zeigt er plötzlich auf die Rückleuchte,
Da war nämlich so ein Kratzer von einem Zentimeter oder so drin.
Damit begründet er dann und erzählt da lang und schreit darüber,
wo das Problem liegt, wo ich denke, also wenn das dein Hauptargument ist,
warum der Bus beschlagnahmt worden ist, dann kommen wir heute nur im Schneckentempo voran.
Und so ging das dann weiter. Plötzlich wurden dann von den Polizisten auch irgendwelche
Sachen angebracht, die nicht mal Teil der Beschlagnahme, also der Mängel in
der Beschlagnahme waren. Das sei ja ein Bus, der eigentlich für 59 Personen
ausgelegt sei. Die können hier doch gar nicht alle mitfahren.
Wo ich dann zurückgefragt habe, aber das ist doch gar nicht Gegenstand der Beschlagnahme.
Im Fahrzeugschein stand ja zum Zeitpunkt schon 12. Das war ja schon umgewinnig.
Und der, was aber auf jeden Fall bezeichnet war, der wollte seine Abschalteinrichtung.
Dann sagt die DEKRA ihm, es gibt keine Abschalteinrichtung hier.
Doch, die muss es aber jetzt geben. Und er sagt, die DEKRA, es gibt hier keine Abschalteinrichtung.
Also sollte, das ist ja der, die Person, die es ihm gesagt hat,
ist, der amtlich anerkannte Sachverständige das muss man sich auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen von der Berliner Polizei,
herangebeauftragte Gutachter und dann sagt er, nein, das passt dem Polizisten
nicht, was macht er dann?
Er geht zur nächsthöheren Behörde dem Autodienst Hoppegarten geht zum Autodienst
Hoppegarten und sagt, jetzt müsst ihr nach einer Abschalteinrichtung das ist mein Witz Ja.
Aber wenn die Deka nichts findet.
Dann tun wir die Nächsten. Wir haben dann irgendwann gedacht,
und dann sind die von Autodienzaube gegangen, sind sie mir angekommen,
haben mir so den Vogel gezeigt, sind dann da rein, und ich mit denen reingehen,
musste alle Knöpfe drücken, ja, da ist nichts, nee, da ist nichts.
Da ist halt nichts, da kannst du nichts
finden, hat halt eine serienmäßige Abstellteinrichtung, aber keine, nee.
Da ist so ein roter, da ist einfach ein Notaus, so was hat ein Bus.
Also, nein, hat er nicht. wir haben dann irgendwann mit einem Anwalt gestanden
und gesagt, wenn es so weiter geht dann steht ja gleich vorne an der Straße
der Polizist und redet irgendwelche Passanten an ob sie für ihn vielleicht noch
die Abstandseinrichtung mal kurz lokalisieren können,
und genau, also das Ende der Geschichte.
Keine illegale Abstandseinrichtung keine illegale Abstandseinrichtung diese
Vorwürfe, sie fallen alle auseinander da und dann kommt der springende Punkt,
den wir am Anfang hatten Das wird dann zum Problem, denn wir haben bei der Ankunft
gesagt, das Fahrzeug war so nicht.
Das Fahrzeug wurde vor Ort als verkehrsunsicher bezeichnet aufgrund der ausgefahrenen Aufbauten.
Haben wir zum Prüfer gesagt, ja, aber das war ja gar nicht so.
Es war auf einer Demos, es musste ja nicht verkehrssicher sein.
Und dann sagt er, ja, aber die Polizei hat mir das Fahrzeug so hier hingestellt,
ich darf es nur so begutachten.
Und dann haben wir einen Mangel bekommen, da hat die Dicke aufgeschrieben, verkehrsunsicher.
Aber wir empfehlen jetzt die Rückgabe.
Moment, ein Punkt ist noch wichtig vor der Rückgabe.
Ich habe ihn gefragt, nämlich gehabt, den Prüfer. Aber jetzt ist es ja abgeschlossen.
Jetzt ist es ja wieder, da haben wir es dann, dann durften wir es zu der,
ich habe dann gesagt, ich will das demonstrieren, wie wir das machen.
Habe es demonstriert, wie es normalerweise ist, Luftdruck ab und so weiter.
Und dann hat der Polizei gesagt, ja, jetzt ist es verkehrssicher.
Also wenn sie jetzt neu begutachten würden, dann wären ihre Mängel weg.
Ja, dann gäbe es die Mängel nicht.
So, dann durften wir wegfahren und in dem Moment haut die Polizei eine Pressemitteilung
raus, das Fahrzeug sei zu Recht beschlagen worden, weil verkehrssicher.
Das ist ja das Absurde. Also wir haben, ich glaube es waren vier Punkte,
die in der Beschlagnahme angeführt worden sind.
Drei von vier haben sich restlos erledigt gehabt durch die DEKRA und einzig
diese Aufbauten für die Demo, weil platt gesagt der Bus ist dann zu hoch und
zu breit, kann man ja so Videokameras ausfahren, das wäre im Straßenverkehr nicht zulässig.
Aber die DEKRA hat nicht mal bemängelt, dass da oben diese Aufbauten drauf sind,
sondern nur, weil man rein theoretisch während der Fahrt ausfahren könnte,
wenn man Druckluft drauf gibt.
Aber dafür muss man vorher an der Seite die Klappe vom Bus aufmachen,
einen Druckluftschrauch anschrauben, dann 10 Minuten, Linus,
du hast es vorhin gesehen, als wir hier angefangen haben, 10 Minuten pumpen
mit bis irgendwann 8 Bar da sind.
Und dann, wenn du dann immer noch nicht gemerkt hast, oh, ich habe alles unter
Druckluft gesetzt hier, dann
könntest du während der Fahrt theoretisch was auswählen, aber das ist auch
Wenn, das ist auch so, dieselbe Story ist, auf deinem Anhänger hast du 20 Rasenmäher,
ja, und die hast du alle verkehrt rum da liegen und dann hast du alle an Strom
angeschlossen, das hast du aber nicht gemerkt.
Und du kannst aber losfahren mit deinem Auto, während da so 20 Rasierklingen
hinten auf deinem Rasenmäher.
Das ist wirklich, oder du hast ein Vorzelt mit Strom und du hast vergessen,
dein Vorzelt abzubauen. Also das ist das, worüber wir hier reden.
Also am Ende gab es ein paar kleine Mängel, die nicht dazu führen,
dass das Auto nicht verkehrstauglich ist und es gab den einen Punkt mit den
Aufbauten, den man ganz einfach klären konnte, indem man irgendeinen Schlauch
hier, ich kenne mich mit dem Bus nicht aus,
aber einen Schlauch rauszieht und dann haben sie jetzt sogar noch vorbildlich
Lampen aufgebaut, dass man sehen würde,
wenn das Ding während der Fahrt ausfahren würde, aus welchem Grund auch immer.
Aber letztendlich lag es an einem Schlauch, der dazu geführt hat,
dass die Polizei das Ding acht Tage beschlagnahmt hat, obwohl man ihn auch einfach
hätte rausziehen können.
Also es ist doch sehr erkennbar eine Willkür, die da stattgefunden hat,
oder? Kommen jetzt die Leute.
Grüßen den Pfarrer. Ja genau, das war die Dekra-Geschichte mit der Berliner Polizei.
Wie wird das jetzt für ein Nachspiel haben? Also das ist dann,
dann bist du in der deutschen Bürokratie gefangen, die haben dir acht Tage die
Karre weggestellt, dann hast du irgendeinen Schaden davon, wenn du Glück hast,
kriegst du jetzt die paar tausende Euro Schaden irgendwann nochmal.
Also den Beschaden, der entstanden ist, den werden sie bezahlen müssen,
was halt nicht bezahlt werden kann, ist der Schaden, den die Demokratie in so einem Moment nimmt.
Ich hatte sowas ganz früher mal, interessanterweise beim Podcasten im Wendland,
wo wir unseren Fahrzeug den Podcastbus beschlagnahmt und da sind wir dann vor
Gericht gezogen und am Schluss kriegst du Recht, aber das ist dann auch,
Recht ist kein, du kannst nicht sagen...
Die Bundestagswahl wird wiederholt.
Oder also niemand ersetzt dir den Schaden oder gleicht ihn aus.
Wir werden jetzt klagen, also nicht nur auf diese Zerstörung unseres Materials,
sondern wir werden natürlich auch diese Maßnahme für rechtswidrig erklären lassen
und selbstverständlich wird die in irgendeiner Instanz dann für rechtswidrig erklärt.
Das ist ja ganz offensichtlich, dass wenn so ein Bus fünfmal bei der Hauptuntersuchung
war, jeden Tag kontrolliert. Niemand findet was.
Dann auf einmal sagt ein Polizist, ich beschlagnahme jetzt und ich werfe dir
noch strafrechtliche Sachen vor.
Natürlich ist es ein schwerer Eingriff
ins Versammlungsrecht und das wird irgendwann so entschieden werden.
Aber man hat nur diesen während den Anfängen Moment davon und kein du kriegst einfach nur Recht.
Werden wenigstens die Gerichtskosten bezahlt?
Ich glaube, wenn man gewinnt, dann muss die Gegenseite deine Kosten zahlen.
Und dann müsste sich so ein Staat irgendwann mal überlegen, ob man sich solche
Polizisten noch leisten kann.
Ja, und der Schaden, der da zur Landeskasse geht, auf jeden Fall,
dafür hättest du wahrscheinlich einen Spielplatz reinigen können oder sowas.
Also, der da jetzt entstanden ist. Also, der Schaden ist wirklich...
Das war ja auch absurd am Anfang. Habt ihr ja gesagt, bevor das Ding hier in
die DEKRA-Halle reinrollt, lasst unsere Techniker das oben mal anschauen,
weil das Ding stand auf dem Polizeigelände und um dann im Nachgang zivilrechtlich
eben Schanzersatz zu fordern, braucht man ja eine Dokumentation von den Dingen,
die kaputt gegangen sind.
Also da hatten wir auch eine Viertelstunde diskutiert, bis man dann Leitern
dran stellen durfte und Fotos machen.
Aber am Schluss wäre es sonst so gewesen, die hätten den Bus überprüfen lassen
und dann hätten sie irgendwann mal gesagt, ja, ja, das war ja dann gar nicht
mehr auf dem Polizeigelände.
Der Vater macht mit seiner Tochter ein Foto vor dem Bus. Es ist so schön.
So, dann hattet ihr euer Auto wieder, euren Bus wieder. Wie lange konntet ihr
damit fahren, bis ihr wieder Ärger hattet?
Also wir haben ihn ja erstmal unter der Prämisse bekommen, dass wir,
wir waren, man muss nicht diese DEKRA-Situation, wir waren wirklich down mit
den DEKRA-Leuten und so überhaupt nicht down mit den Polizisten.
Und der Polizist war am Schluss aber auch nicht mehr down mit den DEKRA-Leuten,
weil er ja das nicht akzeptieren konnte, was hier das Ergebnis ist.
Da gab es dann auch hektisches Hin und Her Getelefoniere mit der Polizeiführung
und die haben dann ihm wahrscheinlich auch nochmal gesagt, komm Alter,
wenn die DEKRA jetzt sagt, die Karre ist okay, dann lass let it go,
weißt du, lass los, die Geschichte.
Und jedenfalls, wir haben dann mit der DEKRA, die hat sich halt von uns Sachen
gewünscht, also mit der DEKRA, das war kooperativ, dann haben wir erstmal gesagt,
ja dieses Zentimeterchen, also diese ein Bruch im Plastik des linken Heckscheinwerfer Also.
Das ist doch wirklich lächerlich, also man muss sich ganz ehrlich...
Es ist ein Mangel, wo du normalerweise beim TÜV gesagt kriegst,
wenn du mit der Karre zum TÜV wirst, kriegst du normalerweise gesagt,
Wiedervorstellung innerhalb von vier Wochen. So lange kannst du einfach weiterfahren.
Das ist trotzdem ein EM, das heißt erheblicher Mangel, aber es gibt diese ein EM und VU.
VU ist verkehrsunsicher, VU gab es nicht, beziehungsweise nur in dieser speziellen
Situation, die die Polizei herbeigeführt hat.
Und EM gab's und da habe ich dem Dekra-Prüfer auch gesagt, schreib mir jeden
EM auf, den du hast, jeden erheblichen Mangel.
Ich löse das eh alles bis morgen, ist ein Mercedes, perfektes Ersatzteilversorgung und so war das auch.
Am nächsten Tag um sieben war da eine neue Lampe dran und dann am nächsten Tag
am Mittag gab's eine Zwischenbesprechung mit dem Dekra-Prüfer.
Wo quasi ihm gezeigt wurde, deine Mängel sind schon alle weg.
Jetzt machen wir als nächstes noch deinen Wunschzettel. Dann hat er gesagt,
hier ein bisschen Beleuchtung, eine Brandmeldeanlage bei den Lithium-Akkus haben wir gemacht.
Und er hat gefragt, ob er den Adenauer als Schulungsfahrzeug für Dekra-Ingenieure benutzen kann.
Also mit dem ist wirklich, das ist ein ganz toller, und weil sein Argument war nicht das.
Er hat gerochen, oder mein Gefühl war, ich will nichts in den Mund legen,
Aber mein Gefühl war, der hat zu uns gesagt, wir dürfen solche Fahrzeuge nicht
als links oder rechts betrachten, sondern wir müssen es als Fahrzeug sehen.
Dem hat es nicht geschmeckt, dass hier eine Art politische Beurteilung vorlag,
egal von welcher Seite. Also es ist wie so, wenn du sagst, vor der DEKRA sind alle Fahrzeuge gleich.
Sozusagen.
So hat er das gesehen, so müssen wir es hin und wenn das in Ordnung ist,
dann ist es in Ordnung und dann ist es auch in Ordnung.
Also hat er uns den, dann hat er mich gefragt, habe ich gesagt,
wann kriege ich von dir diesen Zettel, also wann kriege ich von ihm,
wann sieht es sich mit denen, keine Du-Beziehung, wann kriege ich dieses Protokoll?
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, das mache ich heute Abend fertig und ich so,
na, wir wollen aber jetzt nach Neuenhagen in der Stunde, wir haben jetzt alles
abgearbeitet, wir wollen jetzt los. okay, dann muss ich jetzt weg,
ich schicke es Ihnen gleich per E-Mail.
Für mich ist es schwierig mit dem Sie, weil ich seit 20 Jahren keine aufgehört
habe zu siezen. Aber wenn es sein muss, mache ich es.
Und dann hat er mir das per E-Mail geschickt. Also nach einer halben Stunde.
Kam von ihm dieser Bericht gescannt per E-Mail.
Dann sind wir nach Neuenhagen gefahren und jetzt will ich einen Punkt machen,
weil dort war ein kleiner Protest gegenüber dem Bürgerhaus Neuenhagen.
Dort war eine AfD-Veranstaltung mit Beatrice von Storch.
Es waren die Omas gegen rechts da, die gegen die jetzt, ja, die Linksextremisten. Die Linksextremisten.
Und andere Bürger und Kinder, es gab eine coole Band, die da gespielt hat.
Aber der Protest war, jetzt sag ich mal, klein in dem Sinne,
toll, 200 Leute stehen dort, halten Schilder hoch und haben,
und der Adenauer, der macht kleine Demos groß.
Also, ohne uns, wenn wir da nicht hingefahren wären, wäre das eine kleine Geschichte
gewesen, bestimmt auch in der Märkischen Oder-Zeitung irgendwie als Vierzeiler drin.
Aber wenn dann auf einmal brachial so ein Fahrzeug eingefahren kommt,
was dann auf deren Seite steht, die diese Technik mitnutzen können,
dann wird das Ganze auf einmal zu so einer Szene, die sowohl für Fotografie
sehr interessant wird und alle fühlen sich dann super und denken,
hey, wir haben hier was Großes, alle freuen sich mega, dass das Fahrzeug da ist.
Und das ist auch was, wo ich sage, deswegen ist ja einer der Punkte,
dass wir den Anhörer jetzt nicht,
wieder einstellen, sondern dass der halt bleiben wird. Weil der ist so eine
Art zivilgesellschaftliches Hilfswerk, was solche Proteste enorm stärken kann.
Einen Tag später, also da sind wir noch gut weggekommen. Nächster Tag waren wir...
Da konnte ich einfach hin und wieder weg.
Ja, wobei ich später gehört habe, ich habe später von der DEKRA gehört,
dass die DEKRA, dass die Polizei vor Ort, es hieß auch von der Anmelderin,
die haben gesagt, sie kontrollieren euch direkt wieder. Als wir ankamen,
wurden wir nicht kontrolliert.
Aber ich habe dann später gehört, von der DEKRA Berlin, dass die Polizei dort
die DEKRA dort angerufen hat.
Die DEKRA dort hat in den DEKRA-Zentralrechner geguckt.
Wer hat hier letztlich begutachtet? Hat dann wiederum unseren DEKRA,
den staatlich Bestellten von Berlin, angerufen und da ist er dann sauer geworden.
Die Frage war, kannst du kommen, das Fahrzeug kontrollieren?
Und dann hat der gesagt, wenn ihr wollt, komme ich.
Aber ihr zahlt das und ich finde nichts.
Weil ich habe das heute erst abgenommen.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
So, dann durften wir also nach Hause fahren. Nächster Tag sind wir zur nächsten
zivilgesellschaftlichen Geschichte am Kino Union in Friedrichshagen gefahren.
Und dort hatten wir nur genau bis 1945 Zeit. Auch da war wieder alles super.
Zwischenzeitlich hat es sich gedreht. Die Polizisten haben gesagt,
ihr dürft ja alles, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt.
Also wirklich so, Hauptsache wir haben keinen Ärger mit euch.
Und danach sollten wir zum Hauptstadtstudio und dort hatten wir Termine mit
Jan von Aken von der Linkspartei und mit der Außenministerin Annalena Baerbock.
Beide sollten sich den Adenauer angucken.
Übrigens, in Klammern, vorher war eh schon, wir hatten sau viele Termine und
durch diese ganze Polizeischikane, ich nenne das Schikane, Leute wollten auch
nicht mehr, weil sie sich nicht mehr sicher sein konnten, stimmt hier alles.
Verstehst du, das ist auch eine Diskreditierung auf STVO-Basis von einem legitimen
Fahrzeug und einem Kunstprojekt.
Das Fahrzeug, schau es dir an, das ist ein Kunstwerk und wir hatten auch vorher
schon gesagt, wir fahren zum Robert Habeck, wir fahren zum Leuten hin und zeigen
denen das und die können hier reingucken.
Leute aus der Medienöffentlichkeit und wenn die dann dauernd lesen.
Beschlagnahmt, Strafrecht, Vorwurf, dann sagen die alle, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
womit habe ich es hier zu tun, da hänge ich mich lieber nicht rein.
Auch schwach, aber so war es.
Jedenfalls dieser Tag, wir hauen da ab, 20 vor 8 fahren wir da weg, Vollgas Richtung,
50 Richtung Innenstadt und auf der Strahlerallee werden wir angehalten von der
Polizei. Hallo, zufällige Verkehrskontrolle.
Zufällig?
Ja, genau. zufällig.
Aber zufällig wussten die ganz schön gut Bescheid über den Bus.
Genau, zufällig wollten sie dann sofort sehen, wo ist denn hier,
dann waren sie zu blöd, das zu verstehen, mit dem Druckluft geht oder geht nicht.
Wir hatten ja mit der DEKRA abgemacht, wenn Druckluft vorhanden ist,
dann muss eine Warnlampe angehen.
Und dann so, hier geht aber die Seitenklappe auf.
Ich so, ja, aber das ist ja keine Druckluft, du kannst die immer aufmachen mit
der Hand, auf und zu. Aber warum geht das Licht nicht an?
Ich so, weil keine Druckluft drauf ist. Es war wirklich schlimm.
Ich habe dann zwischenzeitlich auch ein bisschen über mein Headset telefoniert.
Ich habe dann, weil ich so verärgert war, gibt es ja das schöne Marc-Uwe-Klinglied
übers Headset telefoniert.
Da habe ich gedacht, ich rufe meinen Freund an und schimpfe ein bisschen.
Gibt es gute Videos auch, glaube ich, von. Naja, und jedenfalls,
dort wurden wir dann, dann habe ich gesagt, ey, wir haben Termine mit der Bundesaußenministerin
und mit dem Vorsitzenden der Linkspartei am Hauptstadtstudio vor diesem Schlussduell da.
Das ist im Straßenverkehr aber so wenn man unterwegs ist, dann hat man Verspätung
und das wurde so lange hingezogen, bis wir tatsächlich beide Termine verpasst haben,
Wir kamen da an, da war es 21.30 Uhr und 45 ging die Sendung los.
Genau, das war die nächste Kontrolle.
Also 45 Minuten Kontrolle. Ich habe auch wieder einen Anruf von euch bekommen,
war dann auch wieder mit der Polizeiführung in Kontakt.
Sagen wir es so, da war man über diese Kontrolle auch nicht so erfreut oder
hat gedacht, meine Güte, was kommt jetzt da wieder auf uns zu?
Aber der Punkt ist ja am Ende, also zwei Spitzenkandidierende zur Bundestagswahl
konnten nicht interviewt werden von euch.
Drei Tage vor der Bundestagswahl.
Also wir reden über Einflussnahme im Wahlkampf.
Wir wissen, dass die aus Russland, aus den USA von Musk und so weiter passiert
und das, was die AfD auf ihren Social-Media-Kanälen macht, darüber sind wir
uns, glaube ich, auch einig.
Aber dass die Polizei selbst solche Kontrollen durchführt, wohl wissen,
dass ja eine Bundestagswahl bevorsteht und solche Termine dann verpasst werden.
Also wie soll man das denn anders nennen als Einflussnahme auf eine Wahl?
Das ist schon sehr unangenehm also mit wie vielen unterschiedlichen Polizisten
habt ihr denn da zu tun gehabt?
Also ist das einer, der da, oder sind die alle in der gleichen Umkleide oder?
Ne, aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass so eine Art Korpsgeist,
also da entsteht aber, das ist wirklich nur ein Feeling.
Ich weiß nicht, wie da interne Abläufe sind, aber was ich als Feeling generell
hatte, war, dass es der Polizei nicht unbedingt gut geschmeckt hat,
dass so ein Fahrzeug, was aussieht wie eins von ihren durch die Gegend fährt,
Dann aber hammergeil ist, sozusagen.
Es gab auch bewundernde Blicke.
Genau, es kommt auch immer mal wieder, wo die sagen, sag mal,
was hat denn das gekostet?
Und wie lange habt ihr gebraucht? Wow, okay.
Also das gibt es schon auch, aber man hat so das Gefühl, dass in so bestimmten
Leuten, die halt nicht so viel Spaß verstehen,
Dass ich da so eine Art, ich kontrolliere das jetzt, oder im Medial,
weil die Polizei auch im Bedrängnis.
Also ich finde das ja sogar völlig in Ordnung, das Ding zu kontrollieren.
Also ich meine, ihr musstet ja damit rechnen, wenn du dir so ein Ding aufs Dach
baust, was irgendwie, was ist, zweieinhalb Meter mal zwölf, das ist groß wie eine Wohnung.
Also auf so einer Fläche wohnen Leute, wenn sie es sich leisten können in Berlin.
Und dann hast du, so ein Ding baust du dir auf dieses Dach, wo dann oben auch
noch ein paar Meter rausfährt. Da ist ja schon klar, dass du das ordentlich
machen musst, A, und B, dass das natürlich trotzdem kontrolliert wird.
Aber wenn dann irgendwann dokumentiert und klar ist, dass das jetzt,
da gibt es nichts zu holen.
Wenn das Fahrzeug beschlagnahmt war, dann war es bei der DEKRA,
das wusste der Polizist, ja.
Dann wurde es hingeschickt, dann habe ich die DEKRA-Bestätigung bekommen,
alles ist behoben und umgesetzt. Und das war das Lustige.
Dann hat er gesagt, ich will den Schein sehen, dass das freigegeben ist.
Dann habe ich ihm meinen Computer aufgemacht und den gezeigt,
weil ich hatte ihn ja nicht.
Und hat er gesagt, der ist jetzt nicht original.
Der hatte gesagt, kann doch jeder mit Photoshop. Also hat er gesagt.
Guck mal, da ist die Aber ausdrucken können die Leute nicht.
Da ist die Unterschrift, ausdrucken können die Leute nicht. Also wenn du es
auf Papierst, das schaffen die Leute, genau, das ist ein super Argument,
was du gerade ausdrucken kannst,
aber da ist die Unterschrift von euch bestellten, ich habe den nicht bestellt,
von euch bestellten Gutachter, amtlich anerkannte Sachverständiger und du wirfst mir gerade vor,
dass ich gar nichts gemacht habe, mit dem Bus einfach wieder losgefahren bin
und eine DEKRA-Original-Urkunde gefälscht habe, diese Beschlagnahme,
dann bitte, nimm mich fest, wenn du das denkst.
Wer sowas behauptet, muss es auch beweisen können.
Und einfach zu sagen, glaube ich euch nicht. Also das ist einfach eine gnadenlose
Kompetenzüberschreitung auch seitens der Polizei.
Wie viele, mit wie vielen Polizisten hattet ihr da zu tun?
Es waren ja unglaublich viele.
Das sind nicht Einzelne.
Ja, nee, das sind nicht Einzelne, es waren in Berlin schon viele,
war ja immer wieder jemand anders kontrolliert.
Die kriegen auch immer einfach durchgesagt, kontrolliert die jetzt,
bis dann dieses DEKRA-Ding kam.
Danach, glaube ich, gab es keine zentrale Anweisung mehr, kontrollier mal jetzt.
Dann war es eher so verselbstständige Geschichten.
Aber wenn man das alles mit Neuropin, mit Dresden, mit Bremen,
wobei Bremen war ja so, Bremen war alles super. Das ist interessanterweise in
Bremen, kurze Kontrolle, ja perfekt, super geil, fahrt hier bei der Demo mit.
Das haben wir dann auch gesagt, was ist denn mit den Bremer?
Ja, die Bremer, heißt es dann in Berlin, mir doch egal.
Also das ist auch so ein Ding, ist ja auch alles Ländersache,
das heißt, wir werden wahrscheinlich diese Kontrollgeschichte noch weiterschreiben.
Hier oben sind drei so dick gefüllte Ordner mit Gutachten, Zulassungspapieren und allem.
Das ist schon so, wenn du den Polizist jetzt triffst, gibst du ihm halt nicht
so wie in Führerschein, Fahrzeugstelle, so ein Mäppchen, sondern du gibst ihm
halt, ich habe glaube ich, um die 650 Seiten zulassungsrelevant auf Tasche.
Die Deka war darüber übrigens sehr begeistert, wie ausführlich ihr das gemacht
habt. Das habe ich auf jeden Fall auch mitbekommen.
Genau, die Deka meinte, das muss ich erstmal verstehen hier und dann haben wir
denen das einigegeben und die haben sich dann das Gutachten zum Ladungsträger hier oben,
die haben diese Ingenieursleistung anerkannt, weil da wird ja wirklich berechnet,
wie verhält sich das bei einer Vollbremsung eine Vollbremsung wird simuliert,
ist das gut genug gesichert und man kommt halt zu dem beim Ingenieurswesen hast
du einen Sicherheitsfaktor du rechnest das alles aus,
mit 1G und dann teilst du quasi was du hast durch die um wie viel bist du besser
und der Bus hier hat einen Sicherheitsfaktor von 4 nach vorne also bei einer
Vollbremsung nach vorne,
könnten wir viermal so viel Gewicht auf dem Dach haben, wie wir haben. Und wir wären sicher.
Gutes Ding, was? Jetzt sind wir ja beim Gorki und wir fahren auch gleich hier wieder weiter.
Weil hier gibt es dieses Ding, wo ich gar nicht mehr so genau Bescheid weiß,
wo ich eigentlich von Vasili ein bisschen mehr hören wollen würde.
Denn ich bin ja der Vereinsvorsitzende da beim ZPS.
Und ich habe vom Gorki-Theater eine Plakatfläche, eine Posterfläche gemietet für Geld.
Ja, die Kultur in Berlin, die wird ja zusammengespart. Also sehr vorbildlich,
dass Gorki holt sich Geld rein.
Genau. Und hat mir diese Fläche vermietet. Dort habe ich ein Bild aufgehangen.
Also ein Plandruck, wo sich...
Was sieht man denn da? Du kannst das ja mal beschreiben.
Was sieht die, soll beschreiben?
Ja, kann ich gerne machen. Man sieht einen wahrscheinlich bald leider Bundeskanzler,
Merz, der sich fast küssend mit einer faschistischen Kanzlerkandidatin,
nämlich Alice Weidel, in den Arm liegt Und oben drüber steht,
die Grenze ist nicht mehr sicher. Am 23.02.
Wählen gehen. Und noch den Hinweis, dass es von der politischen Schönheit ist.
Also sagen wir mal so, sowas findet man überall im Netz.
Ist jetzt eigentlich nichts Dramatisches, sondern einfach nur ein Kunstplakat.
Wo hängt es? An einem staatlichen Theater, was eine Fläche vermietet hat.
Was passiert? Auf einmal bekommt ein Anruf von der Intendanz bei mir an, von diesem Theater.
Die sagt, die Polizei ist am Gorki und sagt,
ihr hängt jetzt dieses Plakat ab, sonst rufen wir die Berliner Feuerwehr und
die hängen es ab und ihr müsst das zahlen.
Daraufhin, das ist aus meiner Sicht ein Fehler, hat das Gorki das dann abgehangen,
aber da will ich den Vorwurf nicht machen, denn der Vorwurf geht an die Polizei der mir denkt so,
ich sitze zu Hause eigentlich auf dem Weg hier hin und der denkt so,
was um drei Teufels Namen ist jetzt das Problem was ist auch,
also irgendjemand hat die CDU hier Anzeige erstattet gibt es einen staatsanwaltschaftlichen
Beschluss, dass das Plakatbeleidigung ist oder sonst etwas.
Und man denkt sich alles möglich aus. Hat Friedrich Merz sich aufgeregt und
Wegner angerufen und der hat die Dialog...
Wo waren die alle? Wo war das Plakat beim Tod von Walter Lübcke oder sowas kann ja sein.
Und dann denkt man, okay, die werden irgendwas in der Hand haben,
aber meiner Meinung nach ist es so, dass sie tatsächlich das Plakat gesehen
haben und gedacht haben, das lassen wir jetzt abhängen.
Ende der Geschichte.
Viel anders war es auch tatsächlich nicht. Dieses Plakat hängt nämlich eigentlich schon seit dem 15. 16.
Februar. Dann hat irgendjemand aus irgendwelchen Gründen am 19.
Februar, also drei, vier Tage später gemeint, jetzt muss das sofort runter.
Wir müssen prüfen, was auch immer prüfen. Also wenn man ein Problem hat mit
der Abbildung oder dass das eine Beleidigung sein sollte, dann kann man das
ja auch vom Boden prüfen, ohne das Ding abnehmen zu lassen.
Weil man kann es ja so auch sehr viel besser begutachten, das Plakat. Wie groß ist das?
15 mal 7.
Und es lag, also 7 Meter breit, 15 Meter hoch. Aber es war dann,
die Polizei, was sagen wir so, als es dann unten war, unten lag auf dem Boden,
hat die, das lag dann so auf dem Boden zusammengerollt.
Da hat sie festgestellt.
Die Polizei hat gesagt, ja doch nicht.
Na, ganz so einfach war es ja auch nicht, denn erstmal, ihr habt so ein vorläufiges,
Also eigentlich gibt es keine vorläufigen Beschlagnahmeprotokolle,
aber wieder so einen Zettel mit der Beschlagnahmung bekommen,
da hat einfach erstmal die Rechtsgrundlage gefehlt, warum man es jetzt beschlagnahmt,
aber schon mal alles andere provisorisch ausgefüllt und dann,
nachdem es abgehängt worden ist, kommt die Polizei auf die Idee,
ja das müssen wir ja mit der Staatsanwaltschaft klären.
Also Rücksprache mit der Staatsanwaltschaft, die prüft und stellt fest, naja...
Da liegt ja gar nichts vor. Anscheinend, das habe ich jetzt auch nur aus zweiter
Hand, gab es dann noch Versuche irgendwie, Herr Merz oder Frau Weidel oder sonst
wie zu erreichen, ob sie sich von dem Plakat beleidigt fühlen.
Kann ich jetzt nicht bestätigen, würde es aber durchaus zutrauen,
dass man da irgendwie versucht hat, noch was zu konstruieren.
Aber als die Staatsanwaltschaft gesagt hat, das Ding ist von der Meinungsfreiheit
und auch von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt, dann musste man das wieder aufhängen.
Und da hätte man ja vielleicht auch erwarten können, wenn die Polizei da schon
so einen Fehler macht, dass sie das Ding wieder selber aufhängt.
Haben sie dann natürlich aber auch nicht gemacht.
Naja, das war die Geschichte. Wir haben es danach aber auch nochmal im Innenausschuss angesprochen.
Weil, also auch hier haben wir wieder diesen Fall, das ist ja auch ein Aufruf wählen zu gehen.
Zumindest wählen zu gegen rechts, finde ich eine sehr gute Empfehlung in dieser Zeit,
ist ja auch öffentlichkeitswirksam, auch da erstmal ist das faktisch dennoch
eine temporäre Beschlagnahme, die passiert ist, auch wenn sie jetzt nur zwei,
drei Stunden gedauert hat, ist aber eine temporäre Beschlagnahme,
die erfolgt ist und zwar offensichtlich rechtswidrig an der Stelle.
Wir haben dann im Innenausschuss am Montag darauf,
also das war dann schon der Montag nach der Wahl, das auch nochmal angesprochen,
da hat sich auch erst die Polizei versucht irgendwie so darzustellen,
dass man es ja hätte abnehmen müssen, um es erst zu bewerten.
Also vollkommen unlogisch an dieser Stelle und dass man den Fallvorgang ja aufarbeiten
werde, sagte die Polizeipräsidentin, die Innensenatorin sagt,
wir haben es schon aufgearbeitet.
Bin ich einmal reingegangen und habe gesagt, ja Leute, wenn, also,
Wenn etwas falsch gelaufen ist, dann muss man sich dafür entschuldigen.
Das ist ja auch das Mindeste.
Also die Grundrechte sind ja Abwehrrechte der Bürger gegen den Staat und die
wurden hier offensichtlich verletzt, wenn auch nur sehr kurz.
Aber es hat ein Grundrechtseingriff stattgefunden, der wahlrelevant war.
Und da mussten wir dann auch erstmal nachbohren, weil die Innensenatorin hat
in ihrem Einleitungsstatement gesagt, wer einen Fehler macht und ihn nicht zugibt,
der begeht einen Zweiten.
Ja, aber so richtig entschuldigen wollte sie sich erst nicht erst auf Nachfrage.
Hat sie dann zumindest gesagt, es war ein Fehler.
So eine halbherzige Entschuldigung.
Bei mir hat sich niemand entschuldigt. Ich bin ja eigentlich der Betroffene
der Maßnahmen, wenn du es so willst, oder wir als Künstlerkollektiv.
Und es ist ja so, ja, ich entschuldige mich. Das ist ja so wie so ein mürrisches Kita-Kind.
Hier, Hannelore, du musst dich aber jetzt hier entschuldigen.
Ja, nee, dann sagt sie, ja, okay, ich entschuldige mich. Aber du musst ja eigentlich
sagen, hey Linus, es tut mir lau. Also das ist eigentlich so ein Entschuldigung.
Ja, so ganz überzeugend war es nicht.
Gebe ich zu. Nein, das ist so, ja, okay, ich entschuldige mich,
ja. Aber eigentlich ist die Entschuldigung, das habe ich schon noch abgeklärt,
weder beim Gorki ist eine Entschuldigung angekommen, noch bei uns,
sondern es wurde oft öffentlich irgendwo gesagt, okay, Entschuldigung.
Und der, also ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie kriegt man das irgendwann mal
im Nachgang jetzt, also ich müsste wahrscheinlich, ich werde eh glaube ich nächste
Woche auch da gegen vor Gericht gehen.
Gegen alles mittlerweile hier vor Gericht. Aber die interessante Frage ist,
doch mit so einer Akten irgendwann hat man den Vorgang und dann kriegt man das
auch mit, ob da noch im Nachgang versucht wurde, einen Friedrich Merz zu erreichen. Oder?
Um, hey, fühlst du dich beleidigt?
Kannst du mal bitte schnell Anzeige erstatten.
Ich hatte in dem Moment auch gedacht, was wollt ihr jetzt? Also,
wenn ihr das nicht, wenn du sagst, wir hängen das ab zur Prüfung.
Erstens, Linus hat es richtig gesagt, das kann man viel besser hängen prüfen,
als wenn das Plakat auf dem Mund liegt.
Zweitens fragt man sich, warum musst du das jetzt schnell, bevor du mit der
Staatsanwaltschaft das geklärt hast, machen?
Es ist doch nicht so ein Plakat, was so ein Fluch von Harry Potter hat,
wo Leute sterben, wenn sie dran vorbeilaufen. Also, du siehst das und stirbst.
Sondern es ist doch so, du hast doch alle Zeit der Welt um zu klären,
darf das da hängen oder nicht.
Warum hängst du es ab? Ich verstehe es nicht. Oder ging es dir nur darum,
weil du die letzten drei Fettnäpfchen nicht ausgelassen hast,
dass du jetzt ins vierte auch noch reintreten musst?
Das ist das, was ich mir denke. Die springen ja wirklich über jedes Stöckchen,
was ihr denen hinhaltet.
Also das Plakat bei aller Liebe ist ganz nett, aber das ist jetzt so wirklich...
Bekannt geworden ist es durch die Berliner Polizei.
Ja, genau.
Es hatte auf Instagram 400.000 Views.
Klar, natürlich infolgedessen.
Es ist dann sofort auf zwei Millionen hochgegangen.
Weil ohne eine polizeiliche Intervention ist das ja jetzt nicht so irre.
Nein, es ist mit eine der am wenigsten provokativsten Sachen,
die wir überhaupt je gemacht haben.
Jemals gemacht haben. Ja, oder?
Wir haben schon auch gedacht, vielleicht ist es auch ein bisschen low.
Aber für die Polizei war es dann doch zu viel.
Also wenn die Polizei genauso konsequent wäre bei Hasskriminalität im Netz und
irgendwelchen rechtsradikalen Sprüchen, Posts, Beleidigungen. Also fände ich ja gut.
An dieser Stelle kann man es wirklich nicht verstehen. Vor allem das Plakat
hing ja schon mehrere Tage. Ich kann an der Stelle auch nur spekulieren.
Es war ja gleichzeitig an diesem 19.02. hier in der Gegend zumindest die Trauerfeier
für den ehemaligen Bundespräsident Torst Köhler, bekanntermaßen CDU-Mitglied.
Also vielleicht hat das einfach einem CDUler nicht gepasst. Also die CDU hat
ja auch ganz viel sich immer beschwert über den unfairen Wahlkampf,
wo ich mir so denke, habt ihr ja mitbekommen, was sie die letzten drei Jahre gemacht hat.
Also es gibt Leute von euch, die kriegen keine Rede ohne Beleidigung gegen den
politischen Gegner hin.
Aber von sowas fühlt man sich dann natürlich gleich angefasst.
Wahrscheinlich auch Verdacht auf Linksextremismus, würde ich sagen.
Unter dem Verdacht steht, ja, ja.
Jetzt ist es so, ihr kommt aber mit diesen Aktionen, wenn man sich das ganze
Bild anschaut, werdet ihr doch eigentlich gerade die ganze Zeit schikaniert.
Das muss man auch so sehen, also das ist auch der Grund, warum wir das diesmal,
das können wir auf keinen Fall einfach jetzt...
Die Sache ist ja rechtlich, ist das Ding gerade theoretisch gelaufen.
Wir müssen jetzt alles neu anfangen, denn unsere Klage gegen diese Beschlagnahme
hat sich durch das Ende der Beschlagnahme erledigt, also von diesem Bus.
Jetzt müssen wir aber nächste Woche ganz viele neue Klagen machen,
wir müssen gegen das hier, also diese Maßnahme für rechtswidrig erklären lassen,
wir müssen die Maßnahme der Beschlagnahme für rechtswidrig erklären lassen und
wir müssen den Schadensersatz für die,
Beschädigung am Fahrzeug einfordern und das sind,
und das heißt, das müssen wir jetzt angehen und das müssen wir alles auch immer tun.
Damit das auch die Polizisten, die nächste Polizeiperson, die ankommt,
weiß oh, wenn ich das mache, dann fange ich mir ein halbes Jahr später einen ein.
Und es ist teuer und es nervt, sowas so nachzubehalten. Aber ja,
man muss hier Flöcke einschlagen für die Kunstfreiheit.
Und auch das wird schwierig erstmal, weil in Deutschland ist es tatsächlich
so, wenn sich eine Maßnahme erledigt hat, dann fällt eigentlich auch der Klagegrund
weg. Das heißt, was es...
Wiederholungsgefahr musst du dann mit geltend machen.
Genau, Wiederholungsgefahr.
Das ist ja hier wohl gegeben, oder?
Fortsetzungsfeststellungsklage, also man muss sagen, okay, ich möchte festgestellt
haben, ob das rechtswidrig war, weil ich in Zukunft Ähnliches oder Gleiches
nochmal machen will und dann nicht in die gleiche Situation geraten möchte.
Erst dann wird auch ein Gericht prüfen, ob es rechtswidrig war.
An dieser Stelle war es offensichtlich rechtswidrig, aber im schlimmsten Falle
sagt dann am Ende ein Gericht, naja, die Wahl ist rum, das Plakat ist runter,
gibt ja eigentlich gar keinen Anlass mehr dazu.
Und dann haben wir auf der einen Seite einen Rechtsbruch begangen durch die
Polizei und auf der anderen Seite einfach keine Möglichkeit mehr, sich dagegen zu wehren.
Was ich hier noch als Abschließungswort ganz lustig fand, war,
also was hier passiert ist noch am Ende, dieses Beschlagnahmeprotokoll war ja
so, dass sie dann die Maßnahme während, also die Maßnahme war im Prinzip abgeschlossen, in dem Sinne,
Poster war ab. Wir mussten es ja dann wieder aufhängen. Sie haben quasi den
Schaden angerichtet und dann einfach abgebrochen und also sie haben quasi in
dem Moment das abgebrochen, haben es halt nicht mitgenommen, nicht beschlagnahmt.
Aber sie hatten ihr Beschlagnahmeprotokoll schon ausgefüllt und dann haben wir
ihnen angeboten, es für sie zu schreddern.
Und das war ja das, was sie danach dann auf Social Videos fanden sie dann unfair,
dass wir das angeboten und stattdessen haben wir es aber dann online verbreitet. Sozusagen.
Also ihr, weil es aber auch zu witzig ist, ich beschlagnahme hier,
das war so angefangen mit Kritzelstift, ich beschlagnahme hier das Fuster.
Genau, dann hat gesagt, ja, was mache ich denn jetzt damit? Jetzt wurde die
Maßnahme gar nicht. Und dann so, ja, wir können es gerne für Sie entsorgen.
Und dann haben sie uns das gegeben und danach haben sie sich drüber geärgert.
Wie kann denn so ein klug sein?
Aber es zeigt ja trotzdem auch, wie dieses Dokument entstanden ist.
Also man füllt erst mal das gesamte Beschlagnahmeprotokoll aus und dann überlegt
man sich die Rechtsgrundlage dazu.
Und genau, das ist ja eigentlich das Problem. Also wenn ich als Polizist Polizistin
eine Maßnahme führe, dann sollte ich in allererster Linie zu allererster,
das lernt man wirklich im ersten Semester, auch im Verwaltungsrecht,
kein Handeln ohne Gesetz.
Also es muss eine Norm gehen, gegen die verstoßen wird und das trägt man dann
ein und dann kann man auch den Rest machen, aber nicht den umgekehrten Weg.
Ich kann nicht zuerst sagen, ich mache erstmal mein Beschlagnahmeprotokoll und
dann setzen wir uns hin und trinken ein Bier und überlegen uns die Rechtsgrundlage
sozusagen, genau, so rum geht's halt irgendwie nicht.
So, wir setzen uns langsam wieder in Bewegung, fahren weiter durch die Stadt.
Wir haben über Behörden und Polizeiwillkür gesprochen. Wir haben über eure... Oha.
Werden wir angehalten? Nee.
Nö. Ah, der Spiegel muss noch eingestellt werden.
Der weite Spiegel.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Dass wir den...
Ja.
Ich würde mich aber gerne, insbesondere für unser ganzes Nerd-Publikum,
noch ein bisschen mit der Technik hier beschäftigen. Wir haben ja gerade kurz
auch die Gelegenheit gehabt, auch mal selber ein Selfie an dem Auto zu machen.
Hier sind ja die ganze Zeit Leute drum, fotografieren sich.
Du hast ja schon gesagt, wir haben den Strom, wir haben diese Sirene,
da sind aber auch Wasserwerfer, Flaggscheinwerfer, Kameras.
Weißt du, was da alles auf dem Dach ist?
Ja, ja, ungefähr. Also ich kann das relativ gut aufkapitulieren,
aber es war wirklich so ein Projekt, wo quasi sich Leute wirklich ausgelebt
haben, die ein erhebliches Interesse daran hatten, das technisch hochzurüsten.
Also wir haben hier verschiedene Türme, die sich aufstellen und an denen Antennen montiert sind.
Also das geht dann bis auf sieben Meter hoch, dann hast du so Antennentürme
und eine Satellitenschüssel, die sich dreht.
Ob das jetzt Störsender sind, mit denen man WLAN-Netze platt machen kann oder
nicht, das wird die Zukunft zeigen.
Dann haben wir alte Kameras, ob das Attrappen sind oder nicht,
will ich auch nicht zu intensiv zu äußern.
Dann haben wir einen Flak-Scheinwerfer.
Vom alten Leopard-Panzer.
Die Personenschützer vor Frau Merkels Haus, die haben auch ganz interessiert gerade geschaut.
Genau, jetzt sind wir bei Frau Merkel direkt vor der Tür lang gefahren.
Die wohnt ja hinterm Gorki sozusagen.
So, dann haben wir diese Sirene E56.
Wir haben die LED-Videowand.
Wie viel Fläche hat die?
4 Meter mal 80 Zentimeter oder sowas. Also irgendwie in dem Bereich.
Ich könnte es nicht genau sagen.
Dann haben wir einen 20.000 Lumen Projektor fest eingebaut.
Nee, Moment, der ist nicht fest eingebaut.
Der ist sicherlich nur auf dem Hauptraum. Er ist in der Ladung fest eingebaut.
Er ist festgeladen sozusagen. sagen.
Und dann haben wir einen, wir haben einmal schon auf 50.000 Blumen erhöht. Da kann man wechseln.
Aber was wir bei Tesla gebraucht haben, waren 100.000 Blumen tatsächlich,
als wir da den Heil Elon gemacht haben.
Aber das war auch nicht mit dem Adenauer. So, dann haben wir hier unten drin
einen 350 Liter Edelstahltank für Flüssigkeiten.
Und wir haben oben quasi quasi vier Möglichkeiten, Wasser abzuschießen oder
halt was auch immer für eine Flüssigkeit im Tank sich befindet.
Wovon man 350 Liter hat.
Genau, dann haben wir außenrum extrem helle LED-Scheinwerfer,
sodass wir quasi einen Platz taghell erleuchten können.
Ich glaube, 4 kW, 4000 Watt LED-Fluter, dann eine Nebelmaschine.
Eine nur?
Eine, aber die ist relativ kräftig, ist der neueste Scheiß und das Fluid,
was wir bei der AfD benutzt haben, heißt Waldbrand-Fluid.
Das ist auch so Feuerwehrübungen aus Holland.
So, das ist das Fluid.
Jetzt haben wir wieder einen technischen Stopp. Ah, ist runtergefallen.
Navi ist runtergefallen. Passiert mir auch immer.
Zum Glück kein Fahrtenschreiber auf dem Dach.
Ja, kein Fahrtenschreiber, genau. Kein Fahrtenschreiber auf dem Dach.
Das kann ich garantieren.
So, was haben wir da noch? Da haben wir 20 Breitband-Lautsprecher auf dem Dach.
Das sind solche Hörner, Horn-Lautsprecher.
Was macht die zu Breitband?
Ja, das heißt, glaube ich, Breitband-Horn. Das heißt, das ist das Typische,
was auch die Polizei auf ihren Autos hat.
Das ist dieser Horn-Lautsprecher, der sich schrecklich anhört,
aber laut ist und weit dringt.
Da kann man sehr laut mit reden. Das ist für Sprachübertragung.
Das sind Drucklufthörner, heißt das, glaube ich.
20 Stück.
20 Stück. Und unten haben wir eine Turbosound, zwei Turbosound-Bassboxen in den Stauklappen.
Wir werden das aber jetzt und deswegen, also genau, das ist eigentlich der Nerd-Kram.
Hier drinnen haben wir eine, haben wir ein TikTok-Recherche,
eine Zelle, wir haben ja diese Zellen hier.
Ja.
Und die Zellen sind ausgebaut, die stehen nicht alle zur freien Verfügung,
sondern wir haben Eine, die eine TikTok-Recherchezelle ist.
Dort speichern wir, beziehungsweise wir speichern überhaupt alle von AfD und
AfD-Bubble-TikTok-Accounts, speichern wir sämtliche Einträge zwischen.
Transkribieren die automatisch und die sind dort alle durchsuchbar.
Also man kann quasi Volltextsuche auf so,
rechtsextreme TikTok-Accounts machen. Das ist ein Recherche-Computer.
Auch der ist übrigens wirklich im Stil der 60er-Jahre gehalten.
Also es ist neuster Kram, aber es wurde von Theaterprofis wirklich wunderbar
in so einen 60er-Jahre-Recherche- Stil gebracht.
Dann haben wir die Alice, die Hey Alice haben wir.
Hinterste Zelle rechts sitzt Alice Weidel und antwortet dir auf Fragen,
wenn du möchtest. Also du kannst Alice alles mögliche fragen.
Sie kann aber nur aus einem ganz bestimmten Trainingsmaterial antworten.
Hat sie dir das etwa auswendig gelernt?
Die echte Alice redet ja drum rum und sagt, sie hat ja eh, glaube ich,
zu viel Koks aus dem Sisyphos gezogen.
Aber sie beleidigt gerne, in den Duellen hat sie das Publikum beleidigt,
sagt immer, das stimmt ja gar nicht, das steht ja gar nicht in unserem Wahlprogramm und so weiter.
Und die Alice, die wir hier mitführen, die antwortet nicht aus ihrem Wahlprogramm,
sondern die antwortet aus den 2400 verifizierten Äußerungen,
die wir ihr einprogrammiert haben, von afd-verbot.de.
Daraus muss sie sich eine Antwort zurechtsuchen. und dementsprechend faschistoid
geht das zu, wenn Alice antwortet.
Und die antwortet mir als Chatbot?
Nee, die spricht mit dir. Du fragst sie und sie antwortet.
Die versteht auch, was ich sage.
Du gehst in und sagst, hey Alice, was hat die AfD mit den Migranten vor?
Und dann antwortet sie dir. Du kannst also an die Zelle gehen und mit ihr sprechen.
Das ist ja stark. Müssen wir gleich mal noch irgendwie, Ich weiß nicht,
ob wir das Equipment darüber kriegen, aber zumindest mal mit dem Handy-Mikrofon dran halten.
Okay, das ist der eine Raum nur.
Das ist Alice, dann gibt es einen TikTok-Raum. Es gibt einen Raum mit 2400 gedruckten
Beweisen für die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit der sogenannten AfD,
der FAC-AfD eigentlich.
Und dann haben wir einen Raum mit Endstufen und Tontechnik und Computertechnik,
die hier diese ganze Medientechnik steuert.
Wir haben sechs installierte Projektoren, hier auch vorne. Hier sind solche
Rollos, also auf der anderen Seite siehst du den.
Da kannst du ein Rollo runterziehen und dann kannst du eine Backprojektion auf
die Fensterscheibe machen.
Ach, jetzt erkenne ich das erst. Deswegen sind aus den Dach,
aus den Höhen-Trägern die Dinger rausgeschneiden.
Weil das ist der Ultra-Kurzdistanz-Beamer, damit der da hinkommt.
Und da können wir Sachen draufwerfen.
Wir haben hier eine Behindertenrampe an dem Bus.
Und die können wir rausfahren, die ist dann eine Bühne. Da kann man so einen
Pult draufstellen und dort können auf Demonstrationen oder sowas die SprecherInnen sprechen.
Wir haben im hinteren Raum die ganze Stromtechnik, Elektrotechnik.
Also da haben wir diese 24.000 Watt Lithium, drei Wechselrichter.
Wir haben im unteren, in den Gepäckfächern zusätzliche Drucklufttanks,
zusätzliche Kompressoren.
Das ist schon wirklich technisch hochgerüstet. Also für die Nerds,
hier ist ein Grafikrechner mit vier Grafik- oder sechs Grafik-Ausgängen.
Hier sind acht Raspberry Pis.
Hier ist ein Rechner nur für den Ton.
Hier ist ein Unify Protect-Ding eingebaut hinten, was mit Festplatten quasi
unsere Videokameras mitschneidet im Quick-Freeze-Verfahren.
Hier sind Dimmerpacks, hier ist wirklich also Technik bis zum geht nicht mehr,
wirklich interessant, dass das Gute ist,
und ich will nochmal einen Schritt zurückgehen, weil wir haben jetzt sehr viel
über diesen Behördenterror gesprochen,
der auch für uns noch weitergeht, aber die wirklich die gute Nachricht an dem
Ganzen, weil ich mag nicht, dass man die Geschichte vom Adenauer als eine Geschichte
der Polizeischikane erzählt, was sie zweifelsfrei auch ist, aber Tatsache ist auch,
ich sehe das als eine Geschichte des Widerstandes, dieses Fahrzeug.
Und er wird ja jetzt bleiben.
Also wir haben, nachdem die Bundestagswahl mit den bekannten Ergebnissen war,
haben wir entschieden, ursprünglich war das Projekt mal letztlich bis zur Bundestagswahl
angelegt und auch bis dahin finanziert.
Und wir haben dann entschieden, das geht nicht. Wir müssen den Adenauer jetzt
eigentlich für immer, aber mindestens jetzt mal für die sehbare Zukunft sichern.
Auf jeden Fall für die nächste Bundeskanzlei.
Genau. Und deswegen wird das Fahrzeug jetzt nicht zurückgebaut,
nicht verschrottet, sondern das bleibt im Einsatz, steht quasi der Zivilgesellschaft zur Verfügung.
Wir werden zu Demonstrationen hinfahren, wir werden zu AfD-Geschichten hinfahren
und dort stören, wir werden die Beweise präsentieren, immer und immer wieder
und wir haben dafür das Crowdfunding, nochmal ein bisschen neue Sachen gibt
es bei uns zu kaufen jetzt,
unter anderem, und das ist jetzt der, da gehe ich in den Marketing-Teil über,
weil die Logbuch-Netzpolitik Shirts sind das ja, die sowieso immer und raubildende Packmaße.
Genau, und das ist super, wenn aber davon der Kleiderschrank schon überquillt,
dann hätte ich im Angebot Adenauer SRP T-Shirts Hoodies,
dann exklusiv, und da sage ich wirklich exklusiv gibt es jetzt auf der-adenauer.de
die Vorbestellung für das Comic der Adenauer in Riesa alles was ich heute über
Riesa erzählt habe und noch viel mehr findet sich alles in diesem Comic die Polizeikontrolle,
die geschnurrten Zigaretten die Hundeattacke in Riesa, wo der Polizist mit seinem
Hund und die Vorgeschichte.
Alice Weidel, Björn Höcke.
Da meinst du, wo der Mann zwischen den beiden...
Wo der Polizist seinen Hund als Waffe benutzt und mit seinem Hund gegen diesen Menschen.
Der sich zwischen den beiden Leitplanken da befindet.
Der übrigens auch von Solibus da war.
Solibus sprechen wir gleich. Also, das gibt es als Comic und das ist wirklich,
das sind 48 Seiten voller Antifaschismus. Faschismus,
Pornografie, Drogenkonsum. Man kann sich das wirklich nicht entgehen lassen.
Und die AfD wird dieses Comic so lieben, dass es vermutlich nach der ersten Auflage zensiert wird.
Das heißt, wer jetzt da in die Geldanlage geht, das wird es nur noch zu absoluten
Mondpreisen auf dem Schwarzmarkt geben im Anschluss.
Das heißt, ich kann nur raten, sichert euch das Comic der Adenauer in Riesa.
Und ganz brandneu. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die ein Problem damit haben, aufs Klo zu gehen.
Das kann ich euch jetzt lösen, denn wir haben jetzt das Original-AFD-Toilettenpapier.
Also wir haben die Gesichter von Alice Weidel, Björn Höcke, Tino Chrupalla und
das AfD-Logo auf Toilettenpapier gedruckt.
Und so wird wirklich jeder Toilettengang zur absoluten Freude.
Und auch das gibt's alles jetzt. Das kann man sich abstauben und gleichzeitig
den Adenauer für die nächsten Jahre sichern. und ich meine, das ist ein absoluter
No-Brainer, muss man jetzt vorbeigucken.
Das ist dieses Toilettenpapier, das interessiert mich.
Wie viel kriege ich denn? Kauft man das in einer Rolle oder in Zehner? Ist das vierlagig?
Es ist dreilagig. Dreilagig muss reichen, vor allem das muss auch schon so ein
bisschen durchweichen.
Also von der Sache, man ist auch immer, ich weiß nicht, aber jetzt wird es so
in die Toilettenpapiergeschichten, aber man guckt ja immer nochmal drauf, ob noch was war.
Also zumindest habe ich das meinen Kindern so beigebracht, dass wenn man sich
den Popo abwischt, dann schaut man nochmal. und das ist dann immer ein fantastischer
Anblick. Jedes Mal, man ist dann...
Man will gar nicht richtig sauber machen.
Ja, man will gar nicht richtig sauber machen. So, das ist dreilagig, 200 Seiten pro Rolle.
Zwei Rollen ist relativ teurer Spaß, aufs Klo zu gehen, weil zwei Rollen kosten,
glaube ich, 15 Euro oder sowas, aber zehn Rollen gibt es für 50 ungefähr.
Also, das ist natürlich ein teurer Spaß sowas, aber es ist halt auch ein Spaß
und ich kann das nur jedem empfehlen, das wird auf jeden Fall den Toiletten
Gang so revolutionieren, wie
es vorher nur dieses Höckerchen geschafft hat, was da von dem, von den,
von den, kennt ihr nicht diese Einhorn-Hocker, gibt es dieses Hocker-YouTube-Video,
geht es dann in den Shownotes.
Ein Einhorn-Hocker.
Einhorn-Hocker-Klopapier, Toilettenstuhl.
Aber Finanzierung der antifaschistischen Zivilgesellschaft ist ja auch gerade
aktuell ein großes politisches Thema.
Ich würde sagen, gute Investition an der Stelle.
Wenn man mal neutral Immerhin muss ich nicht zu Bundestag, immerhin muss ich
nicht mehr, immerhin kann ich sagen, liebe CDU,
die Menge an Geld, die wir von der Bundesregierung im letzten Jahr bekommen haben, war 0 Euro.
Und sogar, ihr könnt ganz stolz auf den Herrn Wegner, den Bürgermeister von
Berlin sein, weil die Menge an Schaden, die uns,
CDU-geführte Landesregierungen also quasi gegen,
das Gegenteil von der Spende ist ja, wenn ich dir was Gespendetes zerstöre,
die war mindestens 30.000 Euro.
Womit wir tatsächlich über das Geld würde ich schon auch noch mal gerne sprechen.
Also, was hier alles verbaut wurde, ich denke mal, ich weiß nicht,
wie das mit der Arbeitszeit ist, hier reingeht. Hier ist der BND.
Wir suchen Terroristen. Das ist eigentlich eine geile, wir suchen Terroristen, MWD.
Lustig auch, am Zaun kommt dahinter. Also, wenn wir jetzt darüber klettern,
kriegen wir aber, glaube ich.
Ein Problem. Ja, glaube ich auch. Aber die haben, wir suchen Terroristen, MWD.
Echt?
Ja, das war gerade die,
Stellenwerbung vom BND.
20% von denen sitzen jetzt im neuen Bundestag.
Wenn, also jetzt, also die Arbeit, gehe ich von aus, die wurde sicherlich nicht
besonders übermäßig entlohnt, die hier reingeflossen ist.
Ihr habt ursprünglich, ich glaube irgendwann habt ihr eine Viertelmillion,
hattet ihr hier an Spenden einge...
Genau, die ist aber auch weitestgehend ausgegeben. Also die,
Man muss sehen, das Fahrzeug und der Ausbau, also der Ausbau war schon,
sag ich jetzt mal auch aufgrund der Kürze der Zeit deutlich teurer als ursprünglich mal gedacht.
Hier sind in diese Ausbaukosten um die 125.000 Euro.
Dazu kam der Fahrzeug Rohling, dazu kam die Veranstaltungstechnik, die gemietet war.
Jetzt muss die ersetzt werden gegen neue und dann hatten wir wahnsinnig hohe,
Betriebskosten wegen der,
ständigen Polizeischikanen also dann wieder zum Gutachten, dann wurden wir einmal
abgeschleppt, das wurde uns in Rechnung gestellt das kostet wahrscheinlich direkt
die Anwälte nicht pro Bono zweieinhalber zu sein und so läppert sich das so,
dass irgendwann jeder Einsatztag richtig teuer ist sozusagen,
das heißt man kann auch nur hoffen, dass das,
ich sag ja immer,
Die Polizei wird sich an den Adenauer jetzt irgendwann mal gewöhnen müssen.
Denn das hat sie jetzt nicht, also jetzt hat sie ja noch am letzten Einsatztag
hier am Tag der Bundestagswahl die Scheibe eingeschlagen.
Das würde ich gerne nochmal gleich rekapitulieren.
Ja, genau. Aber genau, also der Adenauer bis hier ist auf jeden Fall finanziert
und wir sammeln auch, also es ist wirklich wunderbar, denn die Volksaktie zieht.
Es gibt viele Leute, die sich schon das Klopapier, das Comic und so weiter gesichert haben.
Wir sehen und ich vertraue da fest darauf, dass die Zivilgesellschaft den Adenauer
so lange finanzieren wird, wie es nötig ist. Bin ich mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher.
Der muss ja auch irgendwo geparkt werden.
Ja, genau. Der hat einen Parkplatz.
Der muss natürlich auch bezahlt werden.
Es gibt Diesel, dann du musst alle drei Monate zur Sicherheitsprüfung.
Du musst einmal im Jahr zur Hauptuntersuchung.
Was muss der Sicherheitsprüfung?
Jeder Reisebus in Deutschland muss alle drei Monate zur Sicherheitsprüfung.
Du hast einmal im Jahr Hauptuntersuchung, also TÜV, und dann dreimal Sicherheitsprüfung
und dann wieder Hauptuntersuchung.
Was ist die Sicherheitsprüfung?
Da werden überprüft, ob er richtig bremst, ob alle Beleuchtung richtig ist.
Genau, also da wird so grundlegende Sicherheitseinrichtungen getestet am Fahrzeug.
Und das kostet?
Das ist nicht so teuer, das kostet 190 Euro ungefähr, aber muss da auch immer
hin. Dann musst du ja was reparieren da dran.
Der Unterhalt von so einem Fahrzeug ist relativ teuer, auch ungefähr 800 Euro Versicherung im Monat.
Im Monat?
Ja, 800 Euro Du, das ist halt kein Golf. Wenn du damit gegen ein anderes Auto
fährst, dann ist das andere Auto kaputt und der Bus hat eine Kratzer.
Das heißt, das ist tatsächlich die Haftpflicht, die sehr teuer ist.
Die Volkasko ist gar nicht mal so teuer. Die Haftpflicht von einem Reisebus ist ja sehr teuer.
Okay.
Das läppert sich alles zusammen, aber...
Umso schwerwiegender dann eben auch, wenn dann ein Einsatz verhindert wird,
weil du ja die laufenden Kosten trotzdem hast.
Hast du trotzdem, eins zu eins, genau.
Also ich glaube, den kannst du ja auch nur, kann man ja wirklich nur an sehr
wenigen Orten in Berlin überhaupt parken, so ein Ding.
Ja.
Wenn er nicht gerade wieder von der Polizei beschlagen hat.
Wenn er nicht von der Polizei geparkt ist.
Kosten haben wir, Klopapier haben wir, Comic haben wir.
Jetzt können wir darüber sprechen, warum wir hier gerade noch an der Tür gewirkt
haben, die euch eingeschlagen wurde.
Ich weiß es noch gar nicht, aber wir sind nicht losgekommen am Anfang, weil die Tür nicht ging.
Und die Tür wurde an dem Tag, nachdem die Polizei sie eingeschlagen hat, repariert.
Und die haben irgendwas nicht richtig angeschlossen, dann ging sie nicht auf
uns zu und wir konnten, deswegen sind wir verspätet los.
Ja, wir waren am Tag der des Wahl also am Wahltag eigentlich 23.
Februar Am 23. Februar waren wir vor der AfD-Zentrale und haben dort um 18 Uhr
also haben dort überhaupt wir sind schon mit sehr schöner Musik gibt es wunderbare
Videos für sind bestimmt dann auch am Schluss klickbar,
und wir waren auch schön in der Tagesschau mit unserem Scheiß-AfD also wir sind
da hingefahren mit einem Lied in Dauerschleife Aber das geht scheiß AfD.
Kann man ja nochmal einspielen.
Und dann vor Ort haben wir es auch gemacht, dort haben wir dann um 18 Uhr die
Sirene angeschaltet, hatte ich vorher,
mit jemandem, der da von der Landespolizei war, eigentlich abgesprochen und der hat dann,
gesagt, also der hat gesagt, wir dürfen die anmachen, aber nur kurz und nach
neun Minuten Sirene hat dann die Polizei die vordere Tür eingeschlagen,
ist hier reingesprungen und dann war, wenn ich hin und habe gesagt, was ist denn los?
Du hast doch gesagt, ja du hast gesagt, nur kurz. Und dann muss ich sagen,
ja, aber ich muss sagen, acht Tage sind lang.
Aber neun Minuten sind bei mir kurz.
Zumindest hätte ich gesagt, wenn ich so zum Späti gehe und sage,
hier, sage ich meiner Freundin, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich brauche kurz,
dann fängt man eigentlich nach neun Minuten an, mich zu suchen, sozusagen.
Ich glaube auch sowieso, und der Grund war Lärmbelästigung.
Und ich glaube sowieso nicht, dass in Berlin schon viele Scheiben wegen Lärmbelästigung
eingeschlagen wurden, also zumindest nicht von der Polizei.
Aber genau, dann wurde die eingeschlagen. Die Leute wurden dann festgenommen.
Kurz. Die Leute, die im Bus waren, die mussten alle auf den Boden.
Das war richtig so Polizisten hier rein, alle auf den Boden.
Gut, Ende der Geschichte. Scheibe eingeschlagen. Ich habe dann gesagt,
so eine Scheibe kann man ganz leicht ersetzen. So eine Demokratie aber nicht.
Und dementsprechend wir haben die Scheibe ersetzt.
Warum haben die die Scheibe eingeschlagen?
Ja, weil sie die Sirene ausmachen wollten. und sie dachten dann auch noch,
sie wollten am Schluss noch meinen Computer beschlagnahmen, weil der hier drin
war und sie dachten, dass der Sirenenton über meinen 3,5mm Klinkenkabel abgespielt wurde,
was auch schon wirklich einiges zu so einem technischen Sachverstand sagt das
ist ja so 108 Dezibel und so ein Sirenen-Sound vielleicht geht's aber,
da brauchst du schon eine ganz andere Anlage, ne sie wollten das aus genau,
sie wollten das ausmachen,
fanden sie nicht gut mit der Sirene.
Ich hab auch einen Anruf von dir bekommen aber von einer anderen Nummer.
Dein Handy haben sie ja einfach mal bezeitlich weggenommen.
Nee, das war halt so, dass ich das, das lag im Bus und dann hatten sie es mitgenommen
und dann war es bei einem von den Festgenommenen, war mein Handy.
Ich kam nicht auf mein Handy, musste ich mich zu Leuten hin,
habt ihr die Nummer von was ich nicht, warum muss ich mal anrufen?
Genau, also das war jetzt aber das, ich glaube jetzt, die sind in so einem Gewöhnungsprozess.
Ich denke gerade jetzt, wo das Teil halt einfach, das gehört zum Stadtbild.
Die Berliner wollen das nicht mehr hergeben.
Ja, also ihr habt das, ihr seid hier beide meine Zeugen und wieder im Steuer genauso.
Das Fahrzeug fährt durch die Innenstadtbezirke und überall gehen die Fäuste hoch.
Also man grinst, es macht wirklich Spaß, weil wir die ganze Zeit irgendwie Leute
Selfies machen, winken, Foto machen, auf das Auto zeigen.
Also das ist schon wirklich.
Das Fahrzeug, das wird jetzt in Berlin zum Stadtbild gehören.
Also das wird bei den kommenden Protesten, es wird natürlich, wir haben im Osten...
Eigentlich ein Erdrutsch-Sieg der Faschisten. Wir haben auch in Berlin eine
deutlich höhere, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele hatten die AfD in Berlin abgeräumt?
15, 10, 12, 13, sowas?
Ich glaube, die sind auch bei 16, 17. Ich habe jetzt auch die Zahlen nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf.
Vielleicht so Mischungen aus Außenbezirken, sehr stark.
Sie hatten ja auch ein Direktmandat geholt, ganz knapp gegen die CDU in Marzahn-Hellersdorf.
Das ist schon auch bedenklich, auch der Typ, der das geholt hat,
also Gottfried Curio, reiner Verschwörungsideologe.
Also ganz krass, was der auch für Reden im Bundestag hält. Und naja,
man könnte es ja mal dem Bundesverfassungsgericht endlich vorlegen.
Dafür macht ihr hier ja auch Werbung, dass die dann tatsächlich mal darüber
entscheiden, dass diese Partei verfassungswidrig ist.
Und wir haben unsere nächste Station erreicht hier im Wedding,
wo wir uns von dir wieder verabschieden.
Du hast ja nur einmal eine Busfahrt mit uns gemacht.
2,70 Euro Kurzstrecke oder was kostet das in Berlin?
Genau, es war jetzt hier ein super Taxi. Vielen Dank.
Ich bedanke mich auch für den Podcast und natürlich für die Aktion.
Wir sehen ja gerade die Rechten, denken sie haben hier eine Diskurshoheit,
die ganzen politischen Debatten sind von rechts getrieben, alles was im Netz
passiert, ist ja wirklich nicht mehr mit anzuschauen.
Umso wichtiger, dass es solche Busse, solche Riesenaktionen auch gibt auf der
Straße von der Zivilgesellschaft.
Danke deshalb an das Zentrum für politische Schönheit und danke für das Gespräch.
Bis bald!
Wir reisen weiter durch Berlin. Das Tutten ist übrigens immer ein Blinker.
Das ist alles in Ordnung hier mit diesem Fahrzeug. Alles einwandfrei.
So, du hast das Ding auf längere Zeit finanziert. Ich meine,
das Geld ist, also da geht schon einiges an Geld drauf.
Aber ich glaube, das Höcke-Mahnmal habt ihr auch noch stehen, oder?
Genau, wir sind ja immer noch der Nachbar von Björn Höcke.
Das sind so Kinder, die man dann dazu hat und die kosten auch alle Geld,
aber man muss auch sagen, dass man,
Man muss auch sagen, dass so ein Kind, das hat man dann auch liebgewonnen.
Also keiner kann sich richtig vorstellen.
Guck dich mal hier um in dem Bus. Das ist wirklich ein Kunstwerk geworden.
Da kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen, ja, wir reißen das jetzt alles wieder ab
und man würde es ja auch gar nicht wieder zurückwidmen können,
sozusagen, weil wir haben über diese Dachträger das auch wieder Nerdkram eigentlich.
Aber das ist ja ein riesiges Stahlding, das kannst du ja nicht einfach,
also das kannst du jetzt nur wieder klein flexen.
Genau, vor allem auch kann dieser Bus nie wieder ein Reisebus werden,
weil diese Umwidmung, also die Dachlast,
wir haben hier durch die Querstriegel des Daches gebohrt und dadurch würde der
Bus jetzt keinen Überrolltest mehr bestehen.
Alle Reisebusse müssen einen Überrolltest bestehen.
Das heißt, es wird statisch nachgewiesen, dass sie intakt bleiben und einen
Überlebensraum bieten, ausreichend, wenn sie auf ihren Kopf liegen.
Also wenn sie quasi überrollen. Deswegen heißt es Überrollprobe nach ICE-Regelung 66.
Und die kann man sich auch mal durchlesen, wenn man ein Statik-Nerd ist.
Jedenfalls dadurch, dass der Dachträger montiert ist und das Fahrzeug umgewidmet
wurde in eine Midi-Busgröße, also hat nur noch, diese ECE 66 gilt ab 23 Sitzplätzen.
Und das heißt, dieser Bus kann nie wieder mehr als 23 Sitzplätze haben,
weil er einfach diese ECE...
23 ist die Menge Leute, die man draufgehen lässt. Ja, genau.
Das ist die Regelung, weil dann, da kommen diese ganzen Fiat,
Ducato und sowas, sind in der Regelung und die schaffen das halt Wenn die aufs
Kopf fallen, dann müssten die wahnsinnig verstärkt werden.
Und der ist jetzt sozusagen umgeschrieben in die Fiat Ducato-Klasse,
wenn gleich viel länger.
Aber Reisebus über fünf Tonnen mit bis zu 23 Sitzplätzen einschließlich Fahrer
oder zuzüglich Fahrer. Und der hat ja nun zwölf.
Aber davon abgesehen, das ist auch so schön geworden, dass wir den weiter betreiben wollen.
Und was mir jetzt noch auf jeden Fall vorschwebt, deswegen können sich die Festivalgänger
auch ein bisschen auf das Fahrzeug freuen.
Ich wollte schon, ich könnte mir den einen oder anderen Acker in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern vorstellen.
Ja und hier und da, also das Fahrzeug kriegt nochmal, also das wird überall
da, wo es gebraucht wird sein.
Aber im Sommer wollen wir auch immer ein bisschen einen Adenauerfloor haben
und da auf dem Adenauerfloor tanzen, oder? Und deswegen wird hier noch was am
Bass gemacht. Es soll ein Basshänger entstehen.
Ein Basshänger.
Und es soll nochmal was auch an der oberen Anlage gemacht werden,
dass wir wirklich hier auch mal 2000 Leute bescheiden können.
Und das ist eines der großen Bauprojekte. Wir haben ja jetzt so eine langweilige Zeit.
Also jetzt gibt es Koalitionssondierungsgespräche, Koalitionsverhandlungen zwischen SPD und CDU.
Das wird jetzt nicht sonderlich progressiv enden, glaube ich,
denn die Schnittmenge zwischen SPD und CDU ist, wo ist die eigentlich?
Die ist so, ja, mehr Auto, mehr Wirtschaft,
mehr Industrie, 50 Cent mehr Mindestlohn, ganz viel CO2-Ausstoß.
Das ist doch so das, oder was hast du, was sind deine großen Erwartungen?
Ich habe keine mehr. Ich bin, also, sicherlich nichts Irres.
Also sicherlich nichts, was uns jetzt irgendwie weiterbringt.
Ja, Bubatz, weiß ich nicht, Bubatz bleibt wahrscheinlich legal,
aber auch das interessiert mich jetzt gar nicht.
Es kommt 15 Jahre zu spät.
Und so wie sie das legalisiert haben, macht es auch irgendwie,
also ich habe noch keinen gesehen, der jetzt, doch ich kenne einen, der hat eine Pflanze.
Es wird aber sicherlich eine Zeit der außerparlamentarischen Auseinandersetzung
und des außerparlamentarischen Drucks, denn es wird natürlich,
also wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit,
um unseren CO2-Ausstoß in den Griff zu bekommen, wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit,
um mal eben kurz die Welt zu retten und das Projekt Klingbeil Merz wird sicherlich keins,
was irgendwie sonderlich diesen Planeten voranbringt oder schützen wird.
Und das heißt, ich gehe davon aus, dass wir deswegen und wegen dem aufkommenden
Faschismus auf jeden Fall viel Protest sehen werden in den nächsten vier Jahren
und viel Bewegung und da wird der Adenauer immer dabei sein und ansonsten halt
auch mal hier und da auf einer Party vielleicht.
Wie ist es denn sonst noch dem Zentrum ergangen?
Also viel Polizeiärger mit dem Adenauer, aber es ist ja über ein Jahr her,
dass wir gesprochen haben.
Ja, es war ganz interessant, weil wir haben ja auch diese, ich habe es vorhin
schon mal anklingen lassen, ich meine,
wir machen ja nun unterjährig, also wir sind ja nicht dafür aufgestellt,
dass wir so eins nach dem anderen, eine Sau nach der anderen durchs Dorf treiben
sozusagen, sondern bei uns ist ja so,
dass Aktionen relativ lange Vorbereitungszeiten haben.
Diesmal musste das alles extremst abgekürzt werden, wir dachten eigentlich,
wir arbeiten hin auf den AfD-Verbotsantrag im März, April Dann kam dieser Regierungszusammenbruch
Da musste alles ganz schnell gehen Den ja dann auch jetzt.
Das nur am Rande der AfD-Verbotsantrag Ist.
Tot Also zumindest erstmal, genau Der ist mit den Bach runtergegangen Und Das heißt, wir haben,
relativ lange Vorarbeit Und deswegen ist jetzt seit dem Deepfake und jetzt nicht viel gewesen.
Was wir aber noch nebenbei gemacht haben, interessanterweise während dem Adenauer
war die Projektion Heil-Tesla.
Nachdem der Elon Musk ja diesen Elon-Gruß gemacht hat bei der Trump-Inauguration.
Und da wurde uns erstmal, also das fand ich nämlich sehr befremdlich.
Verfassungs- Nein, das erstmal, aber vor allem wurde ja auch erstmal gesagt, ja, das ist fake.
Also das wurde, das war gar nicht echt. Und wir haben uns, also auch Philipp
und ich, wir haben uns im Zentrum angeguckt und gesagt, wir bauen ein Mahnmal
neben Höckes Haus, ohne dass er es merkt.
Wir machen Tiger in Berlin-Mitte, stellen wir aus.
Aber einen Beamer auf Tesla, das können die nicht geschafft,
das ging nicht. Das ist bestimmt ein Fake.
Als hätten sie irgendwann mal was, also außer dem Scholz-Video,
was aber auch ein Fake, also da war ja der Fake, das ist krasse.
Aber, also das können wir nicht. Und dann der Werkstutz sagt auch,
nee, war nicht und so weiter.
Dann stellen sie fest, okay, es war doch kein Fake. War echt.
Und sie haben es noch nicht gecheckt. Und es dann die Polizei wegen zeigungsverfassungswidriger,
Symbole ermittelt gegen uns.
Wohlgemerkt gegen uns, die wir das Bild, was es gibt, projizieren und nicht
gegen Elon, der das gemacht hat.
Als Elon diesen Gruß gemacht hat, haben wir gedacht, oh, das ist aber ein Gruß.
Der könnte aber so sein.
Missverständlich. ausgedrückt. Aber als wir ihnen dann zeigen,
eins zu eins, ist es auf einmal Zeigenverfassungswidrig. Aber das wird ja sowieso eingestellt.
Ich denke, also da würde ich fast
sagen, ich glaube, das mussten sie dann wahrscheinlich auch machen, oder?
Dass sie dann sagen, naja, wir müssen einem Anfangsverdacht nachgehen.
Es ist ja nun mal passiert, das wurde gezeigt und gleichzeitig hast du wenigstens
eine Expertenmeinung mehr, die sagt, dass es vielleicht doch einfach ein Hitlergruß war.
Genau, das ist vielleicht auch erinnerbar. Aber das war's, also mehr,
also so haben wir in der Zwischenzeit, ich mein, es war nicht so viel Zwischenzeit, ne? Es war ein Jahr.
Wie viel...
Alles in einem Monat hier zu bauen.
Aber das war harter Stoff. Das war nicht so, dass alle total entspannt waren dabei.
Sondern hier sind, da gibt es interessante Videos, die ich aber nicht öffentlich
zeigen kann, wie hier auf diesem Raum.
Stell dir mal vor, hier arbeiten zehn Leute gleichzeitig drin.
Du bist wahnsinnig.
Mit Werkzeug. Und es gibt aber nur diese Tür und diese Tür zum Rein- und Rauskommen.
Aber Leute haben auch noch irgendwelche Schienen für ihre KS-Säge.
Dann passen sie irgendwas an, müssen wieder raus, müssen wieder rein.
Deswegen auch ja an die ganzen Leute, die auf dem CCC waren,
noch die kleine Entschuldigung, man konnte ja nicht so richtig reingehen,
sondern es eigentlich nur so angucken und da fortschillen, einfach weil es ein
Bauprojekt noch war hier drin.
Ich denke ja, er kommt bestimmt auch wieder zum CCC und dann kann man sich mit Alice unterhalten,
die ganze Nacht, wenn man möchte, in dem Bus, kann noch ein bisschen Technik
einbauen oder umlöten oder machen, wenn man möchte und dann gibt es auf jeden
Fall noch eine Revanche dafür.
Und mehr Bass.
Und mehr Bass, genau.
So, es ist viel ruhiger jetzt geworden. Der Motor ist aus.
Und zwar, weil wir wieder angekommen sind. Und jetzt konnte endlich jemand,
dem ich noch, dem und dem Kollektiv, für das er hier ist, ich in ganz besondere
Art und Weise danken muss.
Denn der Piet, der uns jetzt hier wunderbar durch Berlin chauffiert hat,
ist jetzt auch hier zu unserem Podcast-Setup gekommen und Piet ist vom Solibus e.V.
Und Solibus e.V. ist ein linkes Busprojekt und die Leute von Solibus haben von
der Präsentation über alle Kontrollen,
über die Panne bis zur eingeschlagenen Scheibe und über die Beschlagnahmung
dieses Fahrzeug gelenkt.
Also sie haben quasi immer, jeden Tag über die gesamte Zeit jemanden für uns
gehabt, mit Rat und Tat zur Seite gestanden und deswegen danke Solibus und danke
auch in Vertretung Piet, der jetzt hier sitzt.
Piet, Busfahren, ein Busprojekt, wie gründet man ein Busprojekt?
Ich habe dir jetzt zugesehen, wie du dieses riesige Fahrzeug manövrierst.
Wie bist du dazu gekommen?
Ui, wir haben ja auf unserer Seite so ein bisschen was schon geschrieben,
ihr habt also www.soli-bus.org,
hat eigentlich eine längere Geschichte, weil ich habe von 1993 bis 2001 in der
Buswerkstatt gearbeitet, bin ja auch hier Selle, seit 1979 und da hatten wir
dann in Kreuzberg, dadurch kam ich immer im Bus heran,
ist dann 2001 weggebrochen und bin ja nie weg gewesen, seit 40 Jahren voll dabei,
Das bedeutet, also auch so bundesweit und international dabei gewesen,
bedeutet uns fehlt, was fehlte uns immer?
Irgendeine Mobilitätsgeschichte, wo man mehr Leute mit von A nach B bringen kann.
Sei es in die Aktion, sei es zur Demo, sei es irgendwie um im öffentlichen Raum
den Diskurs zu beteiligen, den politischen und und und.
Und haben wir dann immer wieder diskutiert. 2007 habe ich dann eben ein Konzept
geschrieben mit einer Freundin.
Und dann jetzt 2017, wo ich über Schanze e.V., das ist ein Jugendprojekt im
Buko, die haben so einen Bus, so einen Linienbus.
Und da wurde ich gefragt, Mensch, bitte willst du den solimäßig fahren?
Nur war das für mich der Träger gewesen, weil 2007 war so, dass es juristisch
unklar war, wie wir einen Verein,
wo ja eigentlich alles immer gewerblich ist, also auch bei der Genehmigungsbehörde,
wie kriegen wir das alles, aber keiner kennt sich aus da war dann für mich klar,
okay es geht mit Verein und da gibt es was juristisch und ich bin ja sehr dankbar,
Schanz e.V., die heißen jetzt anders in Buko,
Weil Felix, der hat mich irre gut beraten. Irgendwie hat mir da sehr,
sehr, sehr viel geholfen und so,
das hat dann praktisch eben von 2017 so in die Runde zu gehen,
also bundesweit in meine Netzwerke, so nach dem Motto in Anführungszeichen,
hab das Mandat bekommen,
irgendwie, packt das an, macht das oder so. und,
2018 haben wir dann den Verein gegründet und 2019 haben wir im Juni den ersten Bus gekauft.
Und der gehört jetzt dem Verein, der wird dann in den Dienst der demokratischen
Teilhabe und antifaschistischen Aktionen gesetzt und ihr fahrt damit die ganze Zeit rum?
Genau, wir sind seit Juni 2019 am Start, jetzt haben wir auch zwei Busse irgendwie
und letztendlich hätten wir vielleicht Vielleicht auch drei Busse.
Dazu fehlen uns aber die Aktivisten mit der Lizenz zum Bussefahren.
Deswegen nochmal korrigierend, weil Stefan von Busfahrerinnen redete.
Also wir sehen uns als Aktivisten, die die Lizenz Busse zu fahren haben.
Wir grenzen uns bewusst eben von Busfahrerinnen ab, weil ich kenne das Milieu zu Genüge und so.
Und ich weiß, dass es da total nette, fitte Leute gibt, aber eben ganz viel Scheiße ist irgendwie.
Und deswegen und aber auch, weil wir die Hierarchie abbauen wollen,
wenn wir mit Gruppen unterwegs sind, Dass sie auch wissen, wir fahren die Gruppe
oder sind Teil der Aktion,
Teil der Fahrt als politische Subjekte, mit einem Standpunkt dazu,
wo wir gerade unterwegs sind.
Und nicht einfach ein Dienstleister.
Genau, das betonen wir immer. Wir machen immer vorher eine Reden, sagen wer wir sind.
Wir sind kein Dienstleistungsbetrieb, wollen nicht konsumistisch als die Schnäppchenvariante
gesehen werden, sondern sind Teil der Bewegung und kommen alle aus verschiedenen
politischen Zusammenhängen. machen das alle aus, also in Anführungszeichen ehrenamtlich,
also aus unserer politischen Haltung.
Keiner kriegt Kohle dafür, genau.
Wie kriegt man einen Busführerschein? Also kannst du ja auch nicht einfach in
eine Fahrschule gehen, oder?
Naja, den habe ich 93 gemacht.
Ach du hast, okay, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Also dazu, die hatte von 88 bis 93 eine Selbstwürfelwerkstatt aufgebaut gehabt,
so für die linke Szene, also zum Lernen.
Also auch da ging es mir ganz viel auch so genderübergreifend und thematisch
eben, dass das eine soziale Konstrukt ist, dass Frauen nicht schrauben könnten.
Und da sind super gute, schöne Beispiele vorgegangen.
Irgendwie eine von den Mitschleiterinnen ist jetzt Ausbilderin in Bayern,
also Kfz irgendwie und so.
Ich finde es und 1993 haben wir da aufgehört, weil die Miete so hoch ging und
das hätte unser Konzept beeinflusst und dann wäre es nicht mehr das Konzept
dieser Werkstatt gewesen.
Dann habe ich aber parallel mit einer Freundin und einem anderen Freund den
Buschein gemacht und bin da, wo wir den Buschein gemacht haben,
auch angestellt worden.
Also eben hatten eigentlich vorhin...
Ich würde sagen, das machst du aber wahrscheinlich irgendwie schon mit einem
kommerziellen Hintergrund, weil der Busschein ja wahrscheinlich paar tausend Euro kostet.
Oder zusammen. Das ist tatsächlich so, dass der Busschein wahnsinnig teuer ist. Mittlerweile.
Mittlerweile, bei mir eben nicht, weil ich hatte ja einen Lkw-Schein und deswegen
kamen die Freundin auf mich zu und sagte, Mensch Piet, bis zum September 93,
da gab es irgendein Stichtag.
Wenn du dich da anmeldest, dann wirst du nach den alten Regeln oder Prüfungsbedingungen,
behandelt und dadurch, ich weiß nicht, ich hab vielleicht maximal 1000 Mark
ausgegeben oder so und dann die Prüfung gemacht und dann eben,
wie gesagt, in diesem kommerziellen Fahrstuhlbusbetrieb gearbeitet,
wo wir aber dann dadurch, dass ich da gearbeitet hab, immer an Busse rankamen
und dadurch, dass es so eine Win-Win-Situation war, was hatte ich damals,
kriegst du 10 Mark die Stunde, da hättest du bei Daimler 20 gekriegt,
wenn du schraubst und, wir haben ja auch Motoren überholt, Ich habe ja alles gemacht.
Aber das war so eine Win-Win-Situation. Der Chef Wolle, der heute ein enger
Freund ist, der war uns total solidarisch.
Also war jetzt nicht der politische Mensch, sondern fand das schon irgendwie
gut, war immer ein bisschen irritiert, aber eben tatsächlich immer dahinter
gestellt oder musste mich nun wieder auch bei den Cops auslösen. Und genau.
Das gibt es aber heute auch.
Dass der Chef sich bei den Cops auslösen muss.
Das ist also die Mama.
Oder?
Nee, du brauchst halt jemanden mit Geld. Fällt dir halt der Chef ein.
Du, wenn ich munter in die Werkstatt kommen soll, dann musst du mich aber jetzt
hier beim Abschnitt 61 erst... Genau, genau, genau.
So, jetzt hast du apropos bei den Bullen auslösend, wenn du jetzt hier den Adenauer,
mehrmals gefahren bist und der eigentlich, wenn ich so richtig verstanden habe,
immer Leute aus deinem Kollektiv, dann hast du ja hier dann auch einiges mitgemacht. Was macht dein,
Punktekonto? Was machen deine... Wie ist das, wenn du mit so einer Karre irgendwie
stehst und bist da mehrere Stunden von der Polizei am Tag belästigt.
Naja gut, aber das ist jetzt nichts Neues. Mit dem Solibus stehen wir auch ständig in Kontrolle.
Das hat mich nämlich interessiert. Ich habe gedacht, ich hebe mir die Fragen
einfach für den Podcast auf.
Sind wir nicht exorbitant belästigt worden im Vergleich zu sonstigen Solibustouren?
Naja, doch schon sind wir exorbitant belästigt. Absolut, absolut.
Keine Frage, weil von uns ist noch nie ein Bus beschlagnahmt worden und sie
haben uns nicht irgendwie zu einer technischen Untersuchung gebracht.
Irgendwie, sie haben uns einfach nur immer eben angehalten und eben eigentlich
gegen das Versammlungsrecht verstoßen, weil wir wollten ja zu einer Versammlung,
aber die haben dann irgendwelche Bedrohungsszenarien und da gelten ja dann die Länder,
Polizeigesetze, wo das praktisch an den Bürgern oder Menschen,
den kritischen Menschen vorbeigegangen sind, wie hart schon diese Polizeigesetze
sind, dass Versammlungsrecht dermaßen ausgehöhlt ist, ist ein Witz.
Also wenn ihr mit dem Solibus fahrt, dann wird das Ding auch erkannt und dann… Naja.
Deswegen, also wir veröffentlichen ja auf unserer Startseite immer so Fahrten, die wir machen.
Jetzt sind auch zwei drin oder drei und dann danach dokumentieren wir das, was wir gefahren sind.
Das ist auch archiviert alles die letzten fünfeinhalb Jahre und klar irgendwie,
sei es, dass manche Gruppen es nicht wollen oder wir denken das jetzt taktisch
unklug, das zu veröffentlichen, weil,
also wir sind schon hin und wieder zerlegt worden oder wo wir dann nach Wien
gefahren sind mit einem vollen Bus von Antifas aus Leipzig zu den Identitären,
um eine Gegendemo zu fahren,
dann haben sie uns an der technischen Grenze gleich rausgeholt und dann auch
gesagt, sie wussten schon, dass wir kommen und sie haben es schon gelesen gehabt.
Und also, ja, deswegen bestimmte Sachen veröffentlichen wir nicht.
Jeder Polizeikopfhunter sieht darin gleich, oh, oh, oh, gleich,
da passiert was Böses oder eigentlich nehmen wir eigentlich nur unser Versammlungsrecht
wahr und es ist ja eher die
Interpretation und die Definitionsmacht, die die Cops haben und damit dich aus
dem Spiel nehmen irgendwie, obwohl es dann nachher nicht stimmt.
Die sagen dann immer ja ganz sicher rechtlich werden und dann sage ich auch
immer, das ist so ein Running-Gag-Teil, das wissen sie oftmals schon in der
Situation, dass sie gegen Gesetze verstoßen und wissen genauso,
wenn ich dann nach zwei, drei, vier Jahren Recht in Anführungszeichen bekomme,
hilft es mir wenig, weil ich habe ja mein Recht nicht bekommen.
In der Situation.
Warst du dabei, als der beschlagnahmt wurde?
Also du stehst da an der Reinhardtstraße ist das glaube ich,
und dann klopft jemand und sagt, das ist meiner.
Ich sitze da, dann kommen erstmal zwei von den normalen Hundertschaften und
wollen sie sowieso immer haben, Papiere und Schein, alles klar.
Und dann schleicht auf einmal irgendeinen Polizeikopf rein ohne Hallo und Guten
Tag und Auf Wiedersehen, sondern eben, ja, der Bus fährt heute hier nicht mehr
weiter und der ist beschlagnahmt und wird abgeschleppt. Da habe ich gesagt, nee, stopp.
Irgendwie, da liegen Unterlagen, da ist der ganze Mailverkehr mit dem Abschnitt
5, da sind die mit der Zulassungsstelle und die Gutachten und da ist alles eingetragen
und eben, das ist vor zwei Tagen, da können sie jetzt nicht jetzt kommen und sagt da eben,
kennt da alles, der wird abgeschleppt. Und ich habe gesagt, wie bitte?
Und ich sitze dann so auf dem Fahrerinnen-Sitz und dann so seitwärts,
geht mir zwischen die Beine und ohne Vorwarnung und zieht den Schlüssel ab.
Dann hat er den gehabt, dann ist er draußen gewesen, dann standen die ganzen
Beamten vorne, ich kam noch nicht raus, da dachte ich, naja,
das ist der Respekt, den ihr Menschen entgegenbringt und ihr wundert euch,
dass praktisch oder habt praktisch die Plattform ständig in den Medien,
dass mit euch respektlos umgegangen wird. Aber.
Das, was ich jedes Mal erfahre oder gerade wenn wahrscheinlich dann eben mit
euren, weiß ich, auch euren politischen Scheuklappen uns dann irgendwie irgendwo
in eine Schublade einsortiert, so entsprechend das nicht selten der Umgang mit uns das bedeutet.
Also mit uns wird richtig respektlos umgehen und die Situation war respektlos.
Dann sagt der Beamte, nö.
Heike sagt, naja, was brauche ich denn noch? Der sagt nicht,
guten Tag, greift mir zwischen die Beine und eben sagt, hier loft nicht und
die Unterlagen liegen da und so und nö. Nein, ich habe gesagt, ich habe Abhebung.
Achso, zu dem Cop, der da den Schlüssel gezogen hat, der raus ist,
dann habe ich nur gesagt, also ganz klar, will man feststellen,
ganz klar ist eben, das ist hier, das hat hier nichts mit fachlich und objektiv
zu tun, dass das ideologisch gerade ist.
Und was sagt er dazu?
Das ist Reuschenjagd, nicht dieser.
Und das war der auch, das ist der Polizist, der vor Ort, der hatte sich das,
dem war klar, dass er dahin fährt an diesem Tag, um das Fahrzeug zu beschlagnahmen.
Das Fahrzeug war dort angemeldet, es war einfach klar, das war keine Entscheidung,
die vor Ort gefällt wurde, weil die gesagt haben, oh, das sieht aber auf irgendeine Art und Weise...
Von Pan ist das Auto da, ne?
Nein. Und das war genau der Polizist, der, obwohl uns von der Land...
Über die Politik von der Landespolizei gesagt wurde, wir rufen an,
den Anwalt nicht angerufen.
Dann unser Anwalt ruft genau diese Person, die da morgens steht Und dann den
Autodienst Hoppegarten mit der Suche nach einem Totschalter beauftragt.
Und jeder, der mal in eine Verkehrskontrolle mit ihm kommt, der wird das auch
feststellen. Eine völlig unbelehrbare Person, völlig respektlos gegenüber dem
Betroffenen einer Maßnahme, muss man sagen.
Also als Maßnahme, ich wünsche mir, selbst wenn ich von einer Maßnahme betroffen bin,
Dann wünsche ich mir respektvoll behandelt zu werden, aber nein,
gegenüber dem parlamentarischen Beobachter, Oberlehrerhaft, gegenüber dem DEKRA-Prüfer,
das wurde ihm am Schluss zum Verhängnis.
Dass er selbst noch gegenüber dem bald 60-jährigen DEKRA-Sachverständigen noch
überheblich war mit seiner Totschalter-Geschichte, aber eine ganz furchtbare
Person im Polizeidienst, man muss es einfach so sagen.
Ein Negativbeispiel eines bürgernahen Beamten.
Ich glaube, wir haben damals bei der DIGA-Untersuchung so gewitzelt und haben
so gesagt, so ein Polizist hat oftmals einen Ermessensspielraum und er kann
quasi zugunsten des Betroffenen seinen Ermessensspielraum nutzen oder zu seinen Ungunsten.
Wir waren uns einfach von dieser Art, wie er aufgetreten ist,
sicher, dass er in seinem Leben noch nie Ermessensspielraum zugunsten des Betroffenen
seiner Maßnahme genutzt hat.
Ach, vielleicht ist das ja auch, wenn man nicht gerade gegen die AfD demonstriert,
ein total umgänglicher Typ.
Und du siehst ja aber, mit Solibus kannst du auch eine ganze Sendung eigentlich füllen sozusagen.
Da gibt es immer 14-Jährige, Peter hat wirklich, wirklich gute Storys da.
Aber ich würde gerne noch mal was sagen dazu, wie wir zusammengekommen sind.
Ja bitte.
Weil, also war für mich tierisch schön, weil Stefan ruft mich an,
ich kannte ihn gar nicht.
Irgendwie, ja, ich kenne euch und Solibus und will euch unterstützen.
Und dachte ich, hä, was ist denn das? Und dann habe ich Stefan in die Suchmaschine reingebracht.
Was, Zentrum für politische Schönheit, das ist ja cool, dass die auf uns mehr aufmerksam werden.
Und das hat mich natürlich tierisch gefreut und irgendwie, ich habe das Gefühl, da haben sich zwei...
Das darf man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so laut sagen, auf jeden Fall mental im
Geiste Radikalinskis gefunden.
Das war jetzt mal total schön und jetzt wo es jetzt mit diesem Projekt losging,
wir haben ja vorhin schon erzählt, wir fahren alles das, wo wir auch hinterstehen
können, bedeutet aber, dass vielleicht im Diskurs wir unterschiedlich sind.
Aber eben, das muss einfach nur stabil genug sein, dass wir dahinter stehen
können, weil eben wie in dieser Situation wir auch mit Repressionen rechnen,
also dass wieder angehalten wird, wieder rausgeflucht und dann irgendwie,
je nachdem wie die Cops drauf sind, vielleicht auch aggressiver abgeht,
wie in Frankfurt damals.
Was ist in Frankfurt passiert?
Da waren wir im Dannenwälder Forst. Genau.
Das war dann Rüder Forst.
Ende 2020 und da war Waldbesetzung in einem riesengroßen Ausmaß,
also kann man gar nicht vergleichen mit hier.
Also unglaublich viel besetzt, ich war unglaublich beeindruckt von den Jugendlichen
und das hat nämlich dann veranlasst, dass ich da zweieinhalb Monate dann im
Dannenröder Forst als Shuttlebus auch in die Aktion da war, immer wieder schnell
nach Hause, weil andere Aktionen, die fahren und und und.
Deine Aktion, also wir sind in zweieinhalb Monaten achtmal festgesetzt worden
und komplett zerlegt worden von den Cops.
Und die eine Sache war eben so besonders nach Frankfurt am Main,
weil die haben ja überall die Leute eingeknastet, in Gießen,
Marburg glaube ich und aber auf jeden Fall in Frankfurt auch,
dann sind wir zur Knastkundgebung gefahren und eben in Frankfurt kaum drinnen
sind wir dann gekesselt worden von ganz vielen Polizeifahrzeugen und,
genau und die haben uns dann eben zur Polizeiwache gebracht, in die Polizeiwache.
Weil ihr im Bus gefahren seid.
Naja, wir sind da hingefahren und für sie, also wir haben ja,
war der einzige, wo wir gegen Wege geklagt haben,
April 21 und letztes Jahr war erst der Prozess, im Juni, also vier Fünftel haben
die Kopfrecht gekriegt, ein Fünftel mehr, aber da war dann auch wieder die Gefahr,
die können sich immer auf eine Gefahrenlage berufen.
Und das wird durchgewunken. Und da ist es ja immer eine Frage des Richters und
der Richterin, ob sie so viel Mut haben, einfach das auch mal in Frage zu stellen.
Weil wir sind ständig zerlegt worden. Das war bekannt.
Zerlegt heißt also eingehalten.
Naja und alles rausgeguckt.
Alles raus, genau.
Also alles, aber richtig heftig. Und da war wiederum so, dann waren wir auf
die Wache gebracht worden.
Und ich hatte vorher, aber zum Glück habe ich ein gutes Netzwerk in Frankfurt
am Main. Und da habe ich dann nicht meinen Anwalt, sondern erst mal die angerufen
und habe gesagt, ey, das wird hier irgendwie noch lustig, weil die bringen uns mit Bus auf die Wache.
Und dann eine halbe Stunde später, wo wir auf der Wache waren,
war eine Kundgebung vor der Wache und das hat die völlig angekotzt, die Bullen.
Aber damit waren wir aus der Anonymität raus, was ja so wichtig ist in so einer Aktion.
Dann hatten die noch mitgekriegt, dass es die Beweisfeststellungseinheit 68
ist, dann haben die mir dann SMS rein, um Himmels Willenpiet,
das sind die Hooligans in Uniform.
Nachher hat sich aufgeklärt, dass die Frankfurter Rundschau mal einen Artikel
zu dieser Einheit geschrieben hat und in Anführungszeichen Hooligans in Uniform geschrieben hat.
Und das haben die auch so bewiesen. Die haben die Leute recht heftig rausgeholt.
Leute, die sich haben tragen lassen, haben sie, obwohl die Mitte auf war,
von hinten bis nach vorne geschleift. und eben also wirklich bewusst.
Durch den Bus.
Also jede Kante mitgenommen irgendwie und eine Person und das war mir sehr wichtig
beim Prozess, da haben wir gedacht, wir gewinnen da nichts, aber wir haben eine
Öffentlichkeit jetzt nochmal und das war richtig gut eben,
weil vor dem Gericht waren Lebenslaute etc.
Ganz viele Leute, Aktivistinnen und
Die dann Musik gemacht haben und dann im, der Hörsaal,
der Richtsaal war völlig voll gewesen und mir ging es um eine Person,
weil eine Person im Bus, die sagte eben, sie muss raus, sie muss aufs Klo und
die, und Cops, die witzeln dann rum und da ich vorne sitze,
kriege ich ja mit, was die für Schenkelklopfer, Klopferwitze sich gegenseitig zuschmeißen.
Das kriegen die mal gar nicht mit, ich kriege die ganze Scheiße mit immer.
Du hörst das alles.
Naja, weil ich sitze ja vorne und dann stehen die da draußen und dann ihre blöden Sprüche.
Und das ist eigentlich fast die Regel mit den blöden Sprüchen.
Und dann sagt er, ey, ich habe eine transplantierte Niere, ich muss hier raus. Ich muss aufs Klo.
Und die haben dann weiter rumgewitzelt und wir vorne, also hinten,
die haben es ja gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Wir sind da recht laut geworden und gesagt, vielleicht bringt ihr den mal zum
Klo. sagt, ey, ich habe die ganzen Medikamente mit den Waschzetteln da drin,
und können ja alles sein.
Auf dem Waschzettel steht aber drauf, dass es gegen das Abstoßen der Organe ist.
Man kann auch einfach die Person auf Toilette gehen lassen.
Genau, das ist die einfachste Lösung.
Ohne zu diskutieren, ob die jetzt ihre Niere verliert oder nicht.
Ich gehe einfach auf Toilette und ich werde auch meistens gelassen.
Naja, aber da war es so gewesen, dass die Leute richtig heftig angegangen wurden.
Dann mussten einige aufs Klo, dann wurde unter Gewaltandrohung,
der Journalist durfte nicht filmen, war ein Journalist mit Presseausweis,
durfte nicht filmen, nichts, unter Gewaltandrohung und so.
Und dann war so, denn der Sven, der es betraf, der sagte, irgendwann sagte der,
passen Sie auf, wenn Sie mir das schriftlich geben, dass Sie mir eine Niere
spenden, dann lasse ich mal hier ab und irgendwie.
Und irgendwann hat er gesagt, passen Sie auf, ich rufe jetzt einen Notarzt an.
Und dann haben sie erst reagiert. Also wir waren da vorne schon total laut und
zwar dann irgendwie, wir haben es eskalieren lassen und so.
Auf jeden Fall ist es so, der ist dann rausgeholt worden und musste ja geführt
werden, weil er auch blind war.
Kam ja auch noch hinzu, war auch noch blind. Musste sich von so einem Idioten
führen lassen, wo du so abhängig bist und so verarscht wurdest.
Was stellt sich danach raus?
Der ist ja nicht zum Klo gebracht worden. Der ist zur ID-Behandlung,
erkennungsdienstlichen Behandlung gebracht worden.
Dann ist er, er hat einen Ausweis bei, er war keiner, der den Ausweis verweigert
hat. Dann dürfen sie keine Körperkontrolle machen.
Der musste sich bis auf die Unterhose ausziehen.
Also ein blinder Mensch, und den haben sie immer dann erst auf Klo gelassen.
Irgendwie. Und das war, da hat mich so wütend gemacht. Und der Mensch ist heute im Pflegeheim.
Kriegt immer wieder eher nichts mit, wird aber von Leuten begleitet aus den
linken Strukturen, richtig cool, die mich auf dem Laufenden halten und,
ich habe denen dann so einen Mitschnitt von dem Prozess geschickt und so und
habe gesagt, die sollen ihm unbedingt das geben, wenn er,
aufnahmefähig ist und er hat es dann mitgekriegt und dann haben sie ein Foto
gemacht, also wo er im Rollstuhl sitzt, also das ist ein Mensch mit totalster
Behinderung jetzt und mir Hat er da.
Noch recht bekommen?
Nee, weil er hat ja nicht geklagt, weil das war ihm zu viel gewesen.
Und für mich war so, ich hatte vorher noch in einem Frankfurter Radio ein Interview,
habe ich gesagt, mir ist einfach nur wichtig, eben bei einem ganzen Prozess,
auch wenn es nicht gerichtsrelevant ist, die werden immer sagen,
Herr Weiß, es gehört gar nichts, es geht um verwaltungsrechtliche Sachen.
Aber mich als Kläger müssen sie ja reden lassen. Da habe ich gesagt,
nee, das ziehe ich durch.
Ich erzähle meine ganze Geschichte und mir ist es ganz wichtig für die Würde
von Sven, es laut in der Öffentlichkeit nochmal zu sagen, was da passiert ist
und so und das war richtig cool und das war übelst also das war eine Geschichte.
So einen Busfahrer will man haben.
Deswegen habt ihr den Adenauer nur in den besten Händen hier gehabt, ja.
Genau, also das ist natürlich so, man muss eine gewisse Konfliktbereitschaft
auch mitbringen und man kann nicht der Polizei nach dem Mund reden,
wenn wir der Polizei nach dem Mund reden würden hier,
dann ist das ja, also kann man ja vergessen, dann machst du keine Panne in Riesa,
dann bist du sofort weg, dann liegst du keinen Widerspruch ein gegen eine Beschlagnahme.
Dann stimmst du vielleicht sogar noch zu, dass irgendwas nicht in Ordnung ist,
obwohl alles tausendmal geprüft und in Ordnung ist.
Genau, deswegen ganz großes Dank an Solibus.
Aber wenn du das gerade so guckst und liest, ich würde trotzdem nochmal genau
das sagen, weil damit Leute wissen, wer wir eigentlich sind.
Also eben, ich hab's fast, weil ich hab's...
Ich wollte es dir gerade abnehmen, dass ich das vortrage, aber mach's du, mach gerne du.
Also Solibus ist ein Projekt.
Das Spenden entgegennimmt.
Nee, für uns, was uns wichtig ist, für uns ist wichtig, dass Menschen ohne sexistische,
rassistische und andere soziale,
Diskriminierung und eben nicht, also auch nicht in Anbetracht von finanziellen
Mitteln oder so einfach eben auch in öffentlichen Raum stoßen kann und dann
zu Veranstaltungen und eben anderen Geschichten, bundesweit und europaweit sind
wir jetzt schon unterwegs,
einfach auch ihre Positionen dann kundtun können.
Und eben uns ganz wichtig, so Barrierefreiheit etc. pp. beide Busse haben von
Anfang an einen Rollstuhlift drin.
Und genau, das nur dazu, das war unsere Intention.
Und deswegen könnt ihr da auf jeden Fall auch eure Spendengelder lassen bei,
soli-bus.org Da gibt es IBAN-Bankverbindung, alles was man braucht,
um sich noch eine Spendenquittung abzuholen für dieses Jahr.
Da ist das Geld auf jeden Fall super richtig aufgehoben.
So, damit haben wir es.
Genau.
Ich danke für eine wunderschöne Fahrt im Adenauer SRP Plus mit ich weiß nicht,
auf wie vielen Fotos dieses Auto allein jetzt heute drauf war.
Viele lachende Leute, du bist ja auch immer, aber das waren Leute die kannte es.
Logbuch, Logbuch Netzpolitik auf der Bande vorm Gorgi Theater.
Das war natürlich ein ganz besonderer Höhepunkt für mich. Ich glaube,
das Foto davon werde ich auch mit der Sendung veröffentlichen.
Und ja, wenn ihr den Adenauer in Berlin seht oder egal wo, Fäuste hoch.
Wir alle, die drin sind, freuen sich immer wieder darüber.
Über Gesten, ja.
Eine absolute Freude. So, ich danke euch.
Danke Linus.
Danke dir.
Und bis demnächst.
Bis demnächst. Tschüss.